انا ازعم ان انسان عاقل عاقل مو كويس ها
ما يمكن يا عبد الرحمن لاي عاقل في الدنيا
يشتغل في الصحافه يبحث عن الاساءه لنادي
مثل الهلال اي عاقل اللي مو بعاقل خله هذا
موضوع ثاني تشك في عقلك طيب لا لا لا يمكن
انا اقولها قدام كلام والناس كلهم بيشوفون
مقابلتي لا ابحث عن رضا النصراويين ولا
ابحث عن رضا الهلاليين ولا ابحث انا ابحث
عن الرضا المهني في كثير من الصحفيين
وجودهم قائم على وجود الت يعني هو لو كان
يقف بين كل الانديه لم يصبح له قيمه لا
يوجد فريق يمثل الوطن الا المنتخب الفرق
تمثل انفسها حتى لو كانت تمثل الوطن حتى
لو كانت في بطوله خارجيه حتى لو كانت في
كاس العالم حتى لو كانت في كاس
العالم اهلا هذا فنجان من ثمانيه وانا عبد
الرحمن ابو مالح اليوم في تطورات وتغيرات
ضخمه في مجال الرياضه خصوصا كره القدم في
السعوديه الا ان تطور ما شمل كل شيء
الاعلام واحد منها فحبيت اننا نتكلم عن
الصحافه الرياضيه والاعلام الرياضي في
السعوديه
والمنطقه هل سحب الاعلام الجديد البساط من
تحت الاعلام التقليدي هذا كان سؤال الحلقه
رغم ايماني اللي كان مهزوز وتغير مؤخرا
فصار ايمان ثابت باهميه الاعلام التقليدي
لاسباب عديده اهمها الادوات الصحفيه
المهنيه اللي يحتاجها المحتوى العربي
واللي يفقد جزء كبير منها او يفقد جزء
كبير منها في الاعلام الجديد طبعا الاعلام
الجديد اقل حساسيه من النقد مقابل الاعلام
التقليدي
الحساس جدا وبكون حذر جدا عشان ما حد يزعل
ابدا اختيار ضيفي كان بعيد عن كل قواعد
الحذر ما انتهت الحلقه لو قد نشف دمي
ضيفي العزيز بتال الجوس رئيس تحرير صحيفه
الرياضيه ومقدم برنامج في المرمى على قناه
العربي قبل ان نبدا اطلقنا في ثمانيه
الموسم الجديد من بودكاست مرتده مع
الزميلين عبيد الله العيسي وبندر المشرافي
ومرتد هو بودكاست رياضي يهتم بمناقشه
احداث الكره السعوديه يحاول يعطي تحليل
موضوعي ل مجرياتها اول باول الحلقه
الصوتيه والمرئيه تنشر على قناه اذاعه
الثمانيه في نفس الموعد كل يوم
احد اما الان لنبدا لا انا اشوفك تضيف
ضيوفك قهوه سعوديه زم اي انا ما اشرب
الهيل ايه ما الهيل عندي مشاكل معه صحيه
ام فشرب قهوه سوداء على طول يعني لا لا
تجيك قهوه سوداء يحبها قل انت تقول انك
نسرا ص انا ما اقول الناس تقول بس انت
يعني ما قلت ولم يسالني لا ق سالت عن
الموضوع قلتله ما
انكر يعني
مش ما يمكن ان واحد يعمل في الرياضه ما
يمكن ما يكونه ميول ما يمكن فليش تسوي ما
عندك مي
تحس ما اسوي بس انا اقول طبعا شوف هذه
قضيه
خاسره خاسره جدا انك تقول
للناس فلان بدون ميول يشتغل في الرياضه
قضيه خاصره انك تحاول تثبت لهم فانت امام
حلين اما انك تعمل وتصمت تخلي الموضوع
مواصل او انك تتفرغ له القضيه انك
تناقشها تفرغت انك تناقشها انت تضيع وقتك
ابدا احنا بدينا صح بدينا الحين ه اخسرت
الرياضه
انك تقول ان الرياضه هي اللي فيها الصحف
الميدانيه الحقيقيه وان بقيه الصحف مجرد
علاقات عامه متى قلت انا ذا كلام 2008
يمكن في في الاقتصاديه
اقع انا ما اذكر م قلته بس هو فعلا رايي
يعني انا ما اتذكر انت قلتها
بصراحه لكن هذا واحد من ارائي يعني في زمن
ما يعني على الاقل في الوقت اللي انا
التحك الصحافه ما كان في صحافه حقيقيه غير
الرياضه يعني 2008 ما كان في مثلا 2007
وقت اللي طلعت انت كان في اي لانه اغلب
الصحف اللي كانت موجوده او اغلب التخصصات
الصحفيه خليي اقول كانت قائمه على ما يصل
لها من الجهات الرسميه بشكل او باخر هذا
حقيقي وبعضها ما يزال حتى الان يعني بنفس
الصيغه الرياضه كانت الوحيده اللي
فيها مساحه كبيره من الحركه الميدانيه
وكانت فيها مساحه كبيره من من الصحافه
الميدانيه اللي تعلم الصحفي الحقيقه يعني
حقيقه الصحافه وتعلم المهنه تعلم ادواتها
تعلم شلون يتقابل مع الطرف الاخر في
القضيه او
في في الموضوع الصحفي تعامل مع اطراف
متعدده الرياضه مثلا
كانت كثير عندها مهام خارجيه صحفيه مثلا
يعني البطولات على سبيل المثال يعني عندها
بطولات مختلفه متعدده يعني تلتقي فيها
بشعوب وثقافات واشياء مختلفه اكثر من
غيرها من الاوساط الصحفيه سياسه بشكل
مستمر انا احب السياسه ترى اكثر من
الرياضه الى حد الى حد كبير ومتابع
للسياسه اكثر يمكن في في فتره ما بس
السياسه ما كانت زي الرياضه يمكن تطور
الموضوع الان بشكل كبير الصحافه السياسيه
تطورت الى الى وتعددت يعني القنوات
السياسيه صحفيا وتلفزيونيا و على على
مستوى الاعلام الجديد لكن ما كانت في ذاك
الزمن ما كانت بهذا الشكل ابدا السياسه
ولا الصحافه السياسيه السياسه وصحافه
السياسيه بتفق معك في جزء يمكن اقوللك هو
ان السياسه تطور على فكره ترى عبد الان مش
ضروري ان نتفق مش ضروري ان ن بس مو ضروري
ان نجلس ناخذ لا مش ضروري يعني احنا احنا
الصدق وانا قاعد اقول
الصدق اقول الصدق بس انه انه انا لما اقول
شي وانت عندك وجه نظر اخرى ما معناته ان
احنا يعني نتفق بس عادي بقوللك وجه نظري
تفل وشوف اذا تتفق ولا لاضل فنقدر نقول ان
السياسه تطورت اصبحت اكثر حيويه فيها فيها
هذه اللي انت تقول تقام شعوب وتغيرات
كثيره خلنا نقول انتقاء مع اطراف القصه
الصحفيه ما كانت موجوده ام بس
الصحافه يعني اذا ما كانت موجوده انا ذاك
هي م موجوده الحين يعني يعني الصحافه
السياسيه ما لا لا تطورت يعني تطورت اشياء
كثيره فيها
ا احنا مادري ليش نركز على الصحافه
السياسيه احنا الرياضه اي لا لا مو بس مو
بس الرياضه يعني صحافه صحافه بشكل عام
يعني السياسه نفسها تطورت في اشياء كثيره
في انفتاحها على الصحافه في انفتاحها على
الصحافه وهذا الشيء موجود الان سابقا ما
كان موجود
اتفقنا شوي اتفقنا شوي بس انا بعمم فذا
اذا كانت الرياضيه انت اول تقول انه هي
اللي فيها الصحافه الميدانيه وان الصحف
الثانيه او انواع الصحافه الثانيه انها
مجرد علاقات الاستدلال عبد الرحمن وقطع
كلامك للاستدلال اغلب الصحفيين ت الكبار
اللي في السياسه خرجوا من الرياضه الرياضه
دربتهم يعني نتكلم على عثمان العمير نتكلم
رجل عنده ارث صحفي كبير لا شك بدا رياضيه
تتكلم على محمد تونسي صحفي كبير كبير طبعا
عبد الرحمن راشد الناس تقول بده رياضيه ما
بده رياضيه هو هو راح غطى متمر صح رياضي
لانه لانه كان يعني ما في صحافيين ارسلوه
يعني بس يغطي بس هو ما بدا رياضيه هذ نقلا
عنه
يعني بس هل هذا المشهد سعودي بحث هذه من
الخصوصيه السعوديه ان الناس تبدا في
الرياضه بعدين ينطلقون انا ما اشتغلت في
دول اخرى صحفيا اوكي اطالع عن صحفهم عن
بعد بس اكيد في اشياء مخت خلفه انت تبغى
تجرنا الى موضوع انه ه سبب السياسه ولا
سبب الصحافه اكيد كان السبب في فتره من ال
فرات هي السياسه اكيد بلا شك السبب
السياسه انه السياسه انفتاحها على الصحافه
سبب حقي لا انا ما ابغى الصدق انا ابغى
اعرف سبب شف انا بحط زعم ومن هنا بننطق
انه الصحف او الصحافه السعوديه انها
متدهوره ومن هنا انا ب انطلق يعني اذا
كانت انت تقول الصحافه الرياضيه زمان كانت
ممتازه لا لا ما قلت ممتازه في فرق بين
التقييم وبين وصف الحاله ابد اب اخذ نصا
ان الصحافه ترى في فرق كبير انا اتكلم انا
اتكلم انك انت لما تجي تبغى تدرب واحد على
الميدان كانت الصحافه الرياضيه اوسع لا شك
اي كانت الصحافه الرياضيه فيها ادوات
التدريب اكثر من غيرها في في الميدان على
على سبيل
المثال حتى في
الرقابه حتى في الرقابه كان الصحافه
الميدانيه في تلك
الفتره يعني افقها اوسع بكثير من من بقيه
الاوساط الصحفيه الاخرى في الرقابه وهذا
يعطي ميدان للحركه ويعطي ميدان
ل بين قوسين للابداع احيانا وهذا يعطي
يعني مجال لاشياء اخرى كثيره الى الان ولا
لا مو الرياضه اعلى يعني صحيح انه السقف
نزل على الجميع الرياضه صحيح هذا الوصف
انه نزل
السقف
ممكن ما نزل نزل بمعنى نزل ولكن اصبحت
العين عليه مفتحه اكثر من اول يعني زمان
ممكن تعمل اشياء كثير في الرياضه ما احد
ينتبه لك ترى واحد جاب خبرك ممكن تمسك لك
بني ادم تشذب تشذيب تعلقه في سيخ
شاورما للاسف الشديد ما كانت حتى ادبيات
بس الان لا الان فيه في عين يعني رقابيه
موجوده في قواعد بشكل او باخر حتى في
قواعد اجرائيه عقابيه موجوده ما كانت
موجوده في السابق ابدا ما كانت موجوده ترى
انا لحقت على الفتره هذه اللي انا قاعد
احكي لك فيها انا طبعا اشتغلت صحافه وانا
بالجامعه ف لحقت على على جزء كبير منها
بعدين جاء التسلسل الرقابي اللي بدا يصعد
يصعد يصعد يصعد الى زماننا الحالي ويمكن
ما اسميه ودي اوجد مفرده اخرى غير
رقابي ادق وصف يعني خلينا نقول
اصبح امام النظر في السابق ما كان امام
النظر بصراحه من كان كان القسم الرياضي
الصحافه الرياضيه كانت في مكان اخر عن
العالم معقوله
صحيح لدرجه اني اقوللك انه في كثير من
المقالات تصدق لو ترجع لها تقول لها كيف
نشرت في ذاك
الزمن كان في
زوايا زوايا صحفيه لا تمي للصحافه لا
تنتمي للصحافه زوايا غمز ولمز واشياء م
موجود في اي شيء في الصحافه الا في
الصحافه الرياضيه وتقول شلون تمشي
هذا يعني اي فن من فنون الصحافه هذا تسال
نفسك وانت تقرا يعني فنون الصحافه كلنا
نعرفها الخبر والمقال والتحقيق ووالى اخره
هذا اي فن منها وانت ضعف التصنيف ما تجد
له تصنيف بس كان موجود كان موجود لانه لم
يكن هناك ك عين فاحصه تراقب هذا المشهد و
هذا الوسط في تلك الفتره بس باخذ اذكر
لقائك مثلا مع الامير عبد الله بن
مساعد ي كان رئيس الهلال او يوم ساعد يوم
كان موجود ايام
الامير كان رئيس والله ما اعرف كان بس اذا
تتذكر تذكر حدتك فيه غير الرياضه لا يمكن
بهذه الحده انك تكون مسول صح صحيح حتى لو
كانت القصد ان بالمهن شوف رغم وجود
المهنيه لان بسن حاد وهذ الحديه لا تنطبق
في اي وسط ثاني يمكن يكون يمكن يكون ك
وصفك دقيق عبد الله يعني زعل مني وهو
صديقي الغالي جدا زعلت ذك الفتره بس ان
تناقشنا يعني وصلنا الى الى الى
حلول خلينا نقول وصلنا الى حلول المض وهو
غالي علي جدا يعني صراحه عبد الرحمن ومن
اكثر الناس اللي يتفهمون يعني حتى ادوار
الصحافه
الرياضيه طد انك تص مشهد الصحافه مو
بالرياضه او الصحافه الرياضيه الصحافه في
السعوديه كيف تجد الرياضيه لا لادي
الصحافه اجمالا واذا تبغى بعدين نزل نتكلم
عن الصحافه الحين بكل انواعها
التلفزيونيه والورقيه او الاعلام الكتروني
والاعلام الجديد هي تمر في فتره نشاط هائل
نشاط هائل نشاط هائل الحقيقه احنا نقول
شوف انا اعتقد
انه فتره نشاط تفتقد الكثير من القواعد
الصحفيه المهمه لكن نشاط نشاط موجود هائل
جدا في قفز من المعسكر الثاني لمعسكر
الاعلام الناشطين يعني انا سمعت محاضره
والله نسيت اسمع عشان بس نقول انه هو صاحب
المصطلح اعلام الناشطين ناسي والله واحد
في في واحده من معاهد الصحفيه سماهم اعلام
الناشطين واعلام التقليديين من يقصد
بالناشطين اعلام الناشطين هو الاعلام
الجديد هو اعلام لا يمكن باي حال من نقول
ان غير موجود هو موجود هل هو اعلام فيها م
مو قولان اكثر من قول ولكن هل هو موجود
اكيد انه موجود هل هو
اعلام يتسم او يتصف بالقواعد المهنيه
الصحفيه الحقيقيه
لا ابدا هذا غير غير موجود هل هو اعلام
انكشف في مرحله من المراحل
نعم خلينا نتخيل مثلا الدول والحكومات
والمجتمعات متى عدت الى الاعلام التقليدي
الثلاث سنوات الاخيره فسه كورونا مثلا ليش
رجعوا الناس الاعلام التقليدي عدم ثقه في
اعلام الناشطين لانه علام الناشطين اصبح
يروج اشياء انت يجيك واحد يتكلم طب هذا
مين اللي
يتكلم مادري هذا مين ف الاعلام التقليدي
دائما هو مؤصل اكثر هو صاحب مصداقيه اعلى
وهو عنده قواعده المهنيه الراسخه و ما
يكسر القواعد ما عنده القدره انه يكسر
القواعد الصحفيه الحقيقيه بس اعلام
الناشطين اساسا مين موجوده عنده هذا شيء
من المشهد اللي موجود الان في الصحافه
السعوديه بشكل عام الكلام طويل عبد الرحمن
في موضوع الصحافه ولكن هذا جزء من الوصف
للحاله اللي انا اعتقد انها هي الاكثر
حديث الاكثر يعني اجتذاب للتحليل والنقد
في ه الفتره اللي هو ما بين الاعلام
الجديد والاعلام القديم اوكي اذا بناخذ
الاعلام القديم يعني انك تقول هذا في فتره
توهج وتشوف ف مبنى الجزيره جالس يؤجر الى
عياده احنا احنا قبل شوي قلنا انا ما قلت
فتره تحج هذه عبارتك انت انا الصياغه يعني
لاد الصياغه
نفسك في فرق بين انك تعيد الصياغه وانك
تغيرها لا لا انا اقول فتره نشاط اوكي
فتره نشاط اح نتكلم عن فتره نشاط نتكلم
الان
ا الشركه السعوديه س ار ام جي نشطه جدا
على مستويات عاليه قاعده تفتح قنوات جديده
صح ولا لا هذا نشاط ولا م نشاط نشاط قاعده
تفتح منصات جديده صحيح مختلفه يعني بس مش
مش مش صحيفه ولا لا هذا نشاط هذا نشاط
عالي ام بي سي ايضا عندها نفس النشاط ام
بي سي عندها عندها يعني منصات جديده نتكلم
على شاهد نتكلم على قنواتها الجديده اللي
قاعد تسويها نتكلم عن احتواء واحتضان
القنوات الجديده مثل الثقافيه في الفتره
الاخيره هذا نشاط ولا مو نشاط نشاط تقييم
هذا النشاط موضوع
اخر تكلمت جزئيه عن صحيفه الجزيره انها
قاعد تاجر مبناها هذا هذ جزء من من
الاعلام الجزيره مجرد صحيفه ورقيه اوكي
وتحولت الى يعني صحيفه ورقيه بشكل محدود
وان دائما ما احب اتكلم عن الزملاء لان
انا جزء من الموضوع فمش مش مناسب اني انا
اتكلم عنه ولكن احنا تاخرنا كثير في
الانتقال المرحله ما بعد الورقي الصحافه
السعوديه تاخرت كثير بما فيهم الشركه
السعوديه اللي انا عض
جزء منها تاخرت في فتره من فترات بشكل
كبير وهذا التاخير قاعده تدفع ثمنه الان
هي تحاول ان تختصر الخطوات التي فاتت وفي
احد ينجح وفي احد يعني من الصعب جدا
انه يعوض
مفع من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم
ورفاهيه الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول
سكنيه مبتكره ومستدام مع شركه صفا
للاستثمار المزيد في وصف
[موسيقى]
الحلقه طيب في برضو حوار 2008 كنت مكتوب
كنت تقول ان القارئ لابد ان يرفض ما جرت
به العاده في الصحافه اوكي والصحف يجب ان
تتجرا
وتتجرد لا يتجر القارئ على
شتمها هذا وين كان ما شاء الله يعني كنت
اقول كلام جميل والله كنت تقول كلام ف
سؤالي هل انت باقي بتال
2008 ما زلت ما زلت ما زلت ادفع الثمن
ا اي الثمن اللي دفعت في اثمان كثيره
الحمن يعني تمر فيك وانت اه بس ما تحس
القارئ له 15 سنه رافض رافض ماذا
الصحف ايش خليك تقول ك ايش خليك تقول كذا
يعني رافض الايش بالض تعتقد ان
اليوم الرياضيه وانت رئيسها العربيه وانت
تقدم فيها برنامجك بالمرمى نفس الوهاج
اللي كانت فيها 2008 اكيد لا وبسحب هذا
الوصف على بقيه اكيد ش شو بقوللك شي اول
شيء تعددت المنصات هذا سبب السبب الثاني
احنا في زمن سرعه هائله الناس تبحث عن
السرعه اكثر ما تبحث عن انا بقوللك
تحليلي انا الخاص الناس لم تعد تضبط
ساعاتها على برنامج تلفزيوني اوكي ولكن
الناس من وين تشوفك الان اذا انت سمعت
ممكن تروح تشوفك عن منصات اخرى يعني انا
اقوللك مثلا على سبيل المثال في المرمى
يمكن لا يوجد احد يمكن لا يوجد نفس العدد
السابق اللي الساعه حده جت تحط بالعربيه
بنشوف في المرمى يمكن لا ترى انا اقول
يمكن هذه بين قوسين لانها يمكن تكون 60 40
70 30 50 50 الله اعلم كم تكون النسبه لكن
هو في وقت فراغه بكره يدخل على قناه
البرنامج في يوتيوب يدخل على شاهد يعيد
الحلقه اللي ما يعجبه
يقدم الحلقه اوكي ويشوف اللي يعجبه وهذا
اصبح موجود اذا نرجع ونقول هل الصحافه
الورقيه انتهت نرجع نقول هل التلفزيون
انتهى اجل المواد اللي قاعده تنشر على
السوشيال ميديا من وين
جايه من وين هي جايه من الصح الورقيه
وجايه من التلفزيون بس هل احد يتفرج لا
لاتكلم الحين 70 الى 80 وترى 70 انا مره
يعني جاي
عليهم ترى 80% من المواد اللي تقدم في
تويتر عطني ماده تقدم في تويتر ليس لها
سند اعلامي
واضح ما في 20% عشان بعد نكون موضوعيين
20% خلينا نقول ما في يعني 20% منهم هذا
مفكر
ناقد يقدم نقده من خلال تويتر فقط كمنص
مثلا من خلال اكس اوكي او او طرف في قضيه
اختار انه يعلق عن طريق عن طريق هذه
المنصه لكن بقيه الاشياء الناس ينقلون عن
الاعلام ما يزالون ينقلون عن الاعلام
التقليدي ما يزالون الى الان ممن باللي
تقول والله يعني ما تشوف انه مثلا مثلا
اخبار
الانتقالات عني اتوقع يعني نا ناخذها من
هذا الايطالي شو اسمه لا مو صحيح مو كلها
بس يعني شوف شوف كم بينزل خبر كم التفاعل
كثير من الاخبار اللي نزلها كثير مثلا من
الاخبار اللي نزلها نزلت الرياضيه قبله
والله
اي صحيح نقدر نسوي رس ما في مشكله بس نقدر
نسوي رسى عبد الرحمن انا باخذ كلامك على
انه صحيح ما عندي مشكله بس انت شايف
التفاعل يحطب صحيح شايف وتقدر تاخذ في
التحليل خل اقوللك عبد الرحمن مره انا كنت
في مجلس اوكي ف الرياضيه عندها حساب اسمه
عاجل عاجل الرياضيه من اهم حساباتها اللي
تنقل بس عواجل بس ما تنقل مواد فانا كنت
ارد اراسل الزملاء على خبر عاجل وهم
يرسلوني يعني نشيك على انه متى يصدر انا
انبسطت مره كنت سعيد جدا لما في المجلس
يمكن سته كانوا او خمسه احنا كنا يمكن ع
تقريبا كلهم م تنبيه على رساله عاجل
الرياضيه يعني هم لما يحطون عاجل تنبيه
عاجل الرياضيه حقيقه كنت سعيد كان في واحد
من الاجتماعات ايضا مسؤولين في نفس الوقت
مسؤولين جهه رياضيه نفس الشيء شفته قدامي
هذا ممتاز تبي تقول لي عبد الرحمن ان في
اندفاع لوسائل الاعلام الجديده بما فيهم
فابريزيو مثلا او او غيره هذا صحيح موجود
جمهور دائما يبحث على جمهور الرياضه على
فكره لما تقول له عندنا ست صفقات السنه ذ
وقعنا وخلصوا ست صفقات خلصوا عاد في اصلا
خان يسجل فيها ما في صفقه جديده هم كده
دائما يبحثون على اشياء لكن ما في شك بانه
الاعلام الجديد متابع اكثر من القديم ولكن
انا اعتقد انه 80% من مادتها ما زالت هي
من الاعلام التقليدي اي بس انا بقول لك
يعني فاذا الاخبار صارت تتنوع وممكن الحين
حتى يعني في جزء اخر اللي هو اصبح المصدر
نفسي قادر على نقلها فما عاد الانديه حاجه
بحاجه الى الرياضيه او اي قناه ثانيه
يستطيع انه ينشرها في حسابات هي المنافسه
على الخبر لم تعد هي المضمار الاول ممتاز
فقدت الصحف التقليديه ابدا لا ما فقدتها
100% ولكن لم تعد هي المضمار الاول ممتاز
بصراحه التحليل التحليل ما يزال موجود
واقل اقل من السابق اذا جينا نبغى نتكلم
عن عن ما فقدته فقدت الكثير لا شك ايش بقي
انت تشوف الاشياء المؤسسات نقفلها لا لا
في اشياء يعني مثلا اذا ناخذ الاشياء
الصعبه اللي ما حد يقدر يسويها مثلا
الوثائقيات الرياضيه اللي تبغى تاخذ ما
اعرف الاشياء تحقيقات الصحفيه يعني انا
اتذكر يعني يعني في بعض الاشياء ض في
المرمى اتذكر لك ب الاشياء بس بس قليله
وهذه لا يستطيع عليها اللي سميت الاعلام
الناشط اعلام الناشطين مو انا سميتها بس
عجبني المصط وايده واقف
خلفه ما
مشكله بس هذول ما يقدرون عليها طيب
الاعلام التقليدي او المؤسساتي من هذه
الاشياء اللي
يعني ما في شك انا قلتلك قبل شوي في
مضامير كثيره لم تصبح انت و فيها اصبح
التنافس فيها على اشده لكن انت لا تاخذ
الجزئيات ترى بس وتبني عليها قصه كامله
تكلمت بشكل عام ترى اكيد بلا شك الخبر لم
تعد يعني لم يعد السباق فيه
ا لم يعد هو البطوله الاولى خلينا نقول في
المضمار لكن في جوانب كثيره ما تزال
الفنون موجوده يعني في الصحافه تعطني
الاشياء اللي لا تزال هي الصحافه
التقليديه والصحافه الرسميه او الصحافه
تقيدي ككل اللي لا يزال الثقه الثقه الثقه
اكثر موجوده عند اعتقد انا اعتقد
ا ان ثقه الاعلام الجديد التقليدي ما تزال
موجوده اكثر واكثر لدى المؤسسات الرسميه
لدى الحكومات لدى المجتمع بشكل او باخر
ا اعتقد انه مهارات الصحفيه الحقيقيه ما
تزال موجوده اكثر في الاعلام هذا القواعد
المهنيه ما تزال موجوده اكثر الاعلام
الجديد بشكل او اخر
ا يعني هو اول شيء خلينا نعترف ان اسميه
اعلام ا في شكوك حول هذا الموضوع لكن
بالاخير هو كيان موجود ما تقدر تلغيه نقدر
نقول الاعلام بس مو بصحافه يعني اذا شو
الفرق اذا افترضنا انه الاعلام هو يعني اي
احد يقدر ي يكون اعلامي عادي كيف انه مجرد
انك تقدر تتصل للناس لكن الصحافه يجب انك
تحافظ على مهنيه معينه في اصط بدون انك
تحب تقاطع حتى لو كنت ضي لا لا لا بس احب
يعني
استوضح استوضح يعني عشان بس اني لاحظت انك
تاخذ جزئيات فحبيت استوضح
ابدا لا هو اصلا اذا رجعنا للتعريفات بحنا
بندخل في بحر ير في الاعلام عموما في خلاف
كبير على
التعريفات حتى اكاديميا يعني في خلاف على
تعريف الموضوعيه في خلاف على تعريف
الحياديه الموضوعيه البحثيه هي غير
الموضوعيه الاعلاميه
الحياديه السياسيه غير الحياديه الاعلاميه
يعني في كثير من التعريفات في الاعلام في
جدليات حولها هذه في وفي تعريفات احيانا
تكون متناقضه اللي يقوللك الحياديه موقف
واللي يقوللك لا الحياديه هي كذا واللي
يقوللك الموضوعيه هي اجراءات وقواعد
يقوللك لا الموضوعيه هي انت ضد الذاتيه
التعريفات هذه مختلفه اذا جينا الموضوع ك
تقول لي الاعلام انه ايش كنت تقول الاعلام
انه انه انه اي واحد يعلم الناس وصار
اعلامي هذا التعريف البسيط للاعلام لكن
ايضا في ناس يقوللك اي احد يشتغل بالاعلام
هو اعلامي
كيف اذا انت في مؤسسه مؤسستكم
اعلاميه التي بوي اللي عندك اعلامي كذا
مثلا انا ضربت المثل يعني بالتي بوي بس ك
اصغر افراد هذه المؤسسه الاعلاميه الليي
يقول اعلامي يشتغل وه الاعلام في
الارشيف اعلامي بينما في ناس اخرين يقوللك
تعريف الاعلامي الفرق بين الاعلامي
الاعلامي هو الذي اشتغل في كل المنصات
الاعلاميه برضه هذا تعريف مقبول صح ولا لا
طيب ش ناخذ منهم هذا ولا هذا هل ناخذ
تعريف اذا ارجع واقوللك من البدايه انه في
كثير من الجدليات حول المفاهيم والتعريفات
في الاعلام ابرزها الاعلام ابرزها من هو
الاعلامي ش تعريف بالال الاعلامي والله
شوف انا لا يعني لا الغي التعريف اللي
يقول اي احد يشتغل في جهه اعلاميه ف هو
اعلامي لا الغيه
اوكي ولكن انا اميل الى الاعلامي هو اللي
يشتغل في المنصات الاعلاميه المتعدده انا
اميل
بشكل يعني اكثر من غيره والصحفي طبعا
موضوع ثاني ايه ف الصحفي يختلف
اللا احنا طبعا انا قلت لك انا قلت لك اني
اميل ليس مو معنى هذا الكلام حبيبنا انه
انا ارى انه هذا التعريف القاطع لانه
الجدليات نسبه بيه في هذا
الموضوع بس انا امين له لانه
فيه يعني في تعريف اقرب بالنسبه لي الصحفي
هو ممارس
الصحافه الصحفي هو ممارس الصحافه الصحافه
بفنونها ام يعني ايش تعريف الصحافه
الصحفي الصحفي هو يعني خلينا نقول مارس
الصحافه الصحافه يعني بادوات الكتابيه
الصحافه با ادواتها الميدانيه صحافه
بادوات الاداريه هذا صحفي طيب على قب شي
انت ذكرت الحياه والموضوعيه والانحياز
هل من
المهني ان يكون الواحد يعلن عن ميوله مثلا
في الرياضه او حتى
انحيازه ما تحتاج تعلنها بالوسط الرياضي
بتعلن لا لا ما تحتاج ت فست الرياضي ما
يخلون شي ما
يعرفونه لا هو انا انا ما اميل للاعلان ما
اميل ابدا ابدا
ا يعني شوف بالاخير هم بيقولون لك بيجيبون
ترى تاريخ من ايام ولادتك الى اليوم انت
ايش سويت في الوسط الرياض ما شاء الله
عليهم في هذه الامور ولكن انا ما عميله
انا ما اميله
لانه ما يهمش ميولك ما يهم ما يهم ابدا
المهم انك ماذا
تفعل
الصحافه احمد الفهيد كان قال قبل انه
انا مع الصحافه
المنحاز تتفق معه
منحازه يقوله كنت باسس لو طت منس صحيف
رياضيه رياضيه يجب ان اعلن مي وان انحاز
الق لا فرق فرق عبد حتى الفرق بين اعلان
الميول وبين صحافه منحازه صحافه منحازه
متخذه موقف الصحافه المنحاز ضد الحياد
تماما لا انا ماني مع الصح شوف يمكن احمد
واحدهم من اهم الصحفيين يمكن احمد قصد ان
من الصعوبه تطبيقها ايه انا افهمه كذا انا
افهمه لكن سالفته انه هي الصح لا ما ما
اتفق معها ما اتفق انه احنا نؤسس صحافه من
الحاسه ما اتفق ابدا يعني اذا يقوللك اذا
الصحافه هدفها تجاري وهو مشروع تجاري يجب
ان اعلن ميولي لان يعني التجاره ما تجي
بتوزيع
ال يعني ال
اني اكون عادل بين الجميع وانه اللي بكسبه
بلعب ما اتفق والله لا لا ما اتفق في يعني
مثلا في
ماركه الاسبانيه تعلمها ريال مدريد وناج
تعلن ما تعلن الناس يعلنون تتوقع ما تعلن
لا لا لا ما تعلن لا لا عبدمن ما تعلن ما
تعلن تقارير شو تقول اللي تنقل عن ماركا
مثلا ولا عن اس ولا تقول صحافه ماركا
القريبه من ريال مدريد هذا وصف الصحافه
الاخرى بس هي ما تصف نفسها يعني انا لما
اجي مثلا اقول فلان
الفلان الباحث في الشؤون البريطانيه
العلاقات السعوديه البريطانيه مثلا يعني
هذا وصف صحيح اي فهم الناس تصفها الناس
وسائل الاعلام الاخرى تصفها تصفها تقوللك
انه يعني صحيفه اس ولا صحيفه الماركه
القريبه من ريال مدريد الوادي الكتالونيه
اللي قريبه من برشلونه وهذا وصف
بس بسعا بس هم ما يعلنون ما في مشكله ما
يعلون بس تقدر انت شوف الماركه طيب لما
يفوز برشلونه على ريال مدريد شوف ما
شهم
مدريدي مش بالصيف مثلا ناخذ مثال على زمان
انا صراحه ان من زمان ما تبع الجزيره اقصد
هنا صحيف الجزيره كان صحي الجزيره برضه
توصف بانها هلاليه صح ام ف بس الجزيره ما
يقولون انهم هلاليه يقول
بسق هلالين لا هم ما يقولون شوف عندهم
وعندهم عندهم وعندهم اوكي بس لا م انا
دائما اقوللك انا ودي لاني اشتغل في نفس
المجال ما ما اقترب او ما ودي اطلق اراء
قاطعه تجاه الزملاء اوكي لو سالتي عن نفسي
بجاوب بس ناحيه الزملاء ما ودي اطلق اراء
قاطعه تجاههم لان حق يعني هذا حق الزمال
علي بس بقول ارائي هذا لا يمنع من قول
الاراء الناس كانوا يوصفون الجزيره
والرياض حتى بانهم صحفه الوسطى الهلاليه
هذا صحيح كانوا يصفونهم هل كانت الرياض
والجزيره تقول عنهم طيب هذا اللي كنا
نقوله قبل شوي ما في مشكله بس اذا انا
بسويها ما بعلن مثلا اذا افترضت اني بمشي
مع هذا غير كلام مدرسه احمد اذا بمشي معه
اني انا ببنيها اني انا ابغى اخدم وابغى
اخلي جمهور الهلال يتابعني بالدرجه الاولى
انت سوت خط وسطي الان بين كلام احمد وبين
كلامي تقول ماني معلن بس بسويها هذا موضوع
ثاني هذا موضوع ثاني موضوع ثاني وتجد انه
منطقي انا حقيقه ما اميله ما تميله لا ليش
يعني الصحافه هي الصحافه عبد الرحمن
الصحافه هي الصحافه الحقيقيه اللي ممكن
تقدم ماده تقدم مهنه بغض النظر عن اطرافها
اوكي انت يجب ان تحترمني ل ما اقدمه لا
تحترمني لاني اتفق معك في نفس اللون اذا
كنت بتحترمني عشان اتفق معك في نفس اليوم
اللون انت يوم من الايام بتختلف معي لمجرد
ان اختلفنا اوكي يعني القناعه ما هي
بقناعه راسخه بيني وبينك هي بقاعده صلبه
اللي نقف انا وياك عليها وطبيعي انه حتى
الهلاليين اثنين يختلفون على واحد يختلفون
على لاعب وعلى رئيس وعلى مدرب و اذا
قعدتنا م بصلبه انا دائما انحاز الى
الصحافه ما انحاز الى الكيانات ولا انحاز
الى الالوان ولا انحاز ال ترى اللي سمع
كلامنا ذا يقول اي صدقتك ليش نفس الكلام
اللي قلتلك قبل
شوي مثلا
انت سنتت بس يعرف عنك انك
نصراوي مع ذلك يعني يبان في احيان كثير من
التقارير انك تشد على الهلاليين واجد وال
نصراويين ايضا بس يمكن صوت النصراوي ما
يصل عندك كويس
ي يمكن ما في جمهور كفايه عشان يصل برضو
منطق يمكن عندك انت ما في جمهور كفايه
للنصر او عندك جمهور الهلال اكثر كل وارد
لا تعرف هذه القصه دائما ازليه بيني انا
وبين النصراويين
الهلاليين
ا حبايبنا الهلاليين يعني هم يعتقدون انه
يعني انا ازعم ان انسان عاقل عاقل مو كويس
ها ما يمكن يا عبد الرحمن لاي عاقل في
الدنيا يشتغل في الصحافه يبحث عن الاساءه
لنادي مثل الهلال او لضرار
بالهلال اي عاقل اللي مو بعاقل خله هذا
موضوع ثاني بشك في عقلك طيب ي يمكن واحد
يبحث عن الاضرار بالهلال لا يمكن ليه عشان
لا ولا النصر ولا النصر قاعد اقول لك ولا
الاتحاد ولا الاهلي ولا الشباب ما يمكن
العاقل لا انت ما بحدف انك تبحث عن ضرر
انت انت تشتغل عشان تضرر الناس لا لا لكن
خليني اقوللك شيء ان القضايا احيانا هي
تكون حقيقتها
مضره بالعبد الرحمن ولا ببتال ولا بزميل
ولا بصديقنا ولا هي حقيقه مضره فيك فانا
شو اسوي طيب لا بدي انشرها هذه صحافه
بالاخير هذه صحافه صح اي بس رده فعلك
تجاهها انا عارف انك بتزعل بس يا اخو
والله الشكو الله ح صحف انا عارف انك
بتتهمني بس الشكو الله انت تذهب الى
الذاتيه وتترك الموضوعيه طيب هل بالامكان
ان اعدل الناس في هذا الموضوع ابدا انا في
الوسط الرياضي احمد ربك انك ما تشتغل فيه
ا اتعامل مع ناس علاقتهم بكيانات حب قلب
عاطفيه الرباط عاطفي مو بعقلي الرباط ابدا
ما يكون بالعقل بين بين النادي ومشجعه
ومريت الحب عمي انت عارف هو يرى ناديه
افضل شيء هو لما تجيه تقول له اللاعب
الفلاني ترى صرح ضد فريقك يك ما يخس الله
و لا نادينا ملائكه وانبياء وصالحين
وشهداء ما فيه فمن الصعوبه اصلا انك تقنع
الناس بهذا الشيء من الصعوبه اذا هل تدخل
في هذه المعركه ولا تشتغل شغلك تشتغل شغلك
طيب بس يعني دقيقه والله قللي اللي في
خاطرك شو هطك هل ادري انك هلالي ما عندي
مش لا لا ما
بالعكس بيتنا في هلاليين واصدقائي على
فكره انا في استراحه اللي في الرياض
هنا سبعه هلاليين سبعه نصراويين وسبعه
هلاليين اظن والله العدد كذا بس انه يعني
حول بعض يعني ما في مش وعلى فكره ترنا مع
بعض تدرين متى من سادس ابتدائي الى اليوم
اي ما في شك ما اي احنا ليش نحاول نفصل
نحول الموضوع الى عقيده الناس تختلف في
العقائد بس يعني وهذه حقيقه حتى حد الدعوه
للخلاف في العقيده ما عاد تصبح موجود فما
بالك بال لا لا بس اللي كنت بقوله وبنيجي
للتعصب اللي كنت بقوله انك يعني يبان انك
انت
ماشي اطني ادله
حبيبي
سيبك انت مسوي بحث كويس في الحلقه لا
ضيفني بس
كولف لا تقول ز كف خفش
عامه دقيقه تتذكر خلافك مع سامي تتذكر ايش
كان خلافي مع
سامي لا تقول عناوين لا طيب السنتر يقعد
لا لا لا لا
شوف والله عبد الرحمن شفته ترى سامي عرف
الموضوع زين والله اني سالت سامي سؤال
كرمزيه والله اعلم الله شوف خليني اقوللك
شيء احنا كنا مقبلين على كاس العالم فكنت
انا يعني ركز معي كنت اقول سامي ايش كان
شعورك وانت تسنتر فييه امام المانيا
ثمانيه مرات انا والله في ذيك اللحظه اقسم
بالله شف ومفروض اقسم ترى في لقاء صحفي
لانه يعني كثر الحلف مو بزين ف كنت قصدي
الرمزيه رمزيتك انت ككابتن كيف انت هل
كنتم تشعرون بالمنا احنا كسعوديين
بالخساره القاسيه هذه يمكن الناس ما فهمت
ترى انا التقيت سامي انا وياه في ذيك
الفتره هو كان في دبي وقلتها له قلت ترك
انت نفسك ما فهمتني انت رحت للجانب السطحي
من السؤال انا كان قصدي انه رمزيتك انت
ككابتن رمزيه العاليه اللي هي تعطيك
الاعلى عن اللعيبه الباقيين اوكي لما فعلت
هذا الفعل هل كنت تشعر ربنا في السعوديه
واحنا نتلقى هذه الخساره الثمانيه اللي
كانت ما ورين وجيهنا الناس في الكره بعدها
بفترات طويله والله كان هذا قصدي شوف اقسم
بالله لكن ما فهمني هو ويمكن هو لانه ما
فهمني اجابته كبرت السالفه صارت فيها ضد
ونديه وسامي ترى ما في بيني وبينه خلاف
شخصي على فكره احنا اصدقا الان بعد معارك
عديده ونشوف بعض في الرياض دبي اكثر مو في
الرياض اي لا لا واستمتع بسوالف وما نرجع
للماضي
ترى لا لا انا بقوللك عشان مو ب بوجهك
والله بس يعني انا ادري انك تشجع فريق لا
اشجع اوك لا يشجع لا اشجع يشجع من قبل بعض
الناس لكني انا ما اشجع لكني ادري ان
مهنتك عاليه شكرا والله جد يعني هو رغم ان
يعني اتذكر مثلا تقريرك حق
ايش ي ايش البطوله هذيك القرب ما كانت
بطوله القربو اسمه جائزه جائزه اوكي يعني
ورحت لقيته في شقه موجوده
او كان رائع بالنسبه لي وان هلالي عندي
مشكله وان اتفق انت هلالي هلالي هلالي
هلالي تشوف مباره
هلالو شوف
كيف للا اشك اشك عن اشك عندك وقت تشوف
كوره
انت لا بس يعني انا احس الهين يزعلون منك
لانك حاط حيلك عليهم بقوتك ما اقول
انها يعني باساليب غير مهنيه لا لا لا بكل
مهنيه بس انك ما تسويها مع الفرق الثاني
لاسلام عليكم لا والله تعرف انت لانك
هلالي عايش في اطار الهلاليين كويس في في
محيط الهلاليين يحق انك تقول ذا الكلام
وترى طبيعي لو انا معكم بقوله كويس لانك
ما تسمع وجهه النظر الاخرى ما تش يقولون
وجهه النظر الاخرى
انا في موسم واحد النصراويين هاشتاجات وسب
وشتم وكل شي على فكره لقول نصراوين كل ت
جمهور ك ترى كلهم تتشابهون كلهم زي بعض ما
في حد فرق عن الثاني فروق بسيطه بس
الاتحاديين نفس الشيء الاهلاويين نفس
الشيء يا اخي الاهلاوين يرون واحد من
اسباب الهبوط ما ادري ليش انا مالي دخل
عشان يعرف ماجد
نفيعي ماجد نفيعي طبعا يعني صديق وعزيز
وكل شيء بس ترى ما عرفته لما صار رئيس ما
اعرفه قبل ما عرفت صار رئيس النادي ا
الاتحاديين نفس الشيء هو كل جمهور الانديه
كذا بس انت عايش في محيط الهلاليين لانك
هلالي وتسمع
ويمكن للهلال موسيقى خاصه في اذنك وهذا
طبيعي عند كل مشجع ف تسمعها من هذا الجانب
ايضا جانب اخر خلينا نتكلم على الشكاوي
اللي توصل رؤسائي انا سواء في الع العربيه
توصل من الهلاليين اكثر انا اشوف كويس ومن
النصراويين يمكن يحنون علي يمكن يحنون
يقولون يعني بالاخير يعني يشفعله
كويس لكن والله يقولون يعني يعني انا بجيب
حسابي في تويتر نسوي خنا
نسوي خلنا نسوي رصد انا
وياك اوكي وشف الهلاليين ونصراني ش يقولون
نفس الشي بس ليش تقول هلاليين تجي اكثر
لانهم يزعلون اكثر ولا لانك تشد عليهم
اكثر ولا للنصراويين يتعاطفون معك
الهلاليين اقوى يق
ام سؤال
ثاني بسله على صدق طيب هل تشوف كل الانديه
لانك انت اللي يصلك الهجوم كل الانديه
يجيك الهجوم منهم
بالتساوي بالتساوي ككم بس كفاعل لا
[ضحك]
صراحه انت بتخلي شكاوي تزيد انت بعد لا
والله حاولت يعني افهمك اكثر
بس ثمانيه تكتب نشرات بريديه متنوعه ذكيه
وممتعه تخليك على الطلاع بالتخصص اللي
يهمك والمواضيع اللي تشدك وتساعدك تكتشف
اهتمامات جديده تعرف على نشراتنا عن
الحياه اليوميه والافلام والكتب حتى
كواليس ثمانيه اشترك في اللي ناسبك منها
وتوصلك على بريدك مباشره نترك لك رابط
الاشتراك في
[موسيقى]
الوصف
طيب التعصب موجود على فكره ممكن تراجع
عبدمن تراجع هذه الاشياء والله جدا بغض
النظر عن المقابله بس عشان الاستيضاح
الفردي الشخصي يعني راجع وشف كلهم ترى نفس
كلهم ترى مع الجميع بس انا ما اقدر ترى
على فكره انا ما اقدر ارتمي في معسكر عشان
معسكر الثاني
يرفضني يمكن اني اروح ارتمي في معسكر
النصراويين انا اقولها قدام كلام والناس
كلهم بيشوفون مقابلتي لا ابحث عن رضا
النصراويين ولا ابحث عن رضا الهلاليين ولا
ابحث انا ابحث عن الرضا المهني نحترم كل
الناس احترم شوف وارجع واقول لك من الغباء
المهني المهني انك
تستهدف نادي مثل الهلال او نادي مثل النصر
او جمهور هذا غباء غباء مهني كبير لكن هذا
لا يمنع بانك انت يا اخي تمارس مهنتك كما
يجب صحيح ان احنا انا يعني زي ما قلت لك
علاقه الحب اللي قبل شوي انا قعد اشرحها
لك بين اللي هي دائما مسيطره في العلاقه
بين النادي وجمهور ورغباته وتوجهاته والى
اخره في حتى انا ما بسسم مش لحظات الحب
المجنونه هذه اللي الناس تحكم عليك فيها
انت لك ان تتخيل انه انا اتعامل مع لحظات
الجنون لدى العقلاء ايضا ا يعني هذا هذا
من يعني من اصعب الاشياء كنا مره في صدي
مشترك بيني انا وانت فكنت مره اقول له في
لحظه من اللحظات
يمكن المعنويات نازله كذا على قلت له انا
خلاص
بوقف قال لي ليش قلت له يا اخي عندي فكره
كذا وكذا وكذا قلت له الفكره اللي في راسي
قال لي للت اخي مليت مليت من ذا الجو مهما
سويت انت صحافه وكذا مما حاولت انك تكون
رده الفعل انك انت فلان الفلاني
وبس ما تحكم عليك قاللي لا في ناس عقلاء
وفي ناس وكذا وكذا وكذا الى اخره اخر شيش
قال اللي قاعد ينصحني قال تصدق لو اشتغل
مهنه كان يديني
انتحرت و واحد من كبار الصحفيين مشكله
والله وهذا لا يحدث الا في الرياضه انتقال
العقلاء الى
مجانين
شوف في اجزاء في الخلافات العقائديه يتحول
بس بسيط وطبعا ترى المصطلحات اللي الجوانب
العقائديه في الاعلام ترى ايضا ترها مثيره
لل للجدل بشكل
كبير في امثله كثيره ترى في الموضوع على
سبيل
المثال خل نقولش العق الاعلام هل هو مجبر
انه يقول على موت فلان من الناس شهيد
مثلا في ناس بتفرض عليك انك تقول شهيد هذا
خلاف صحفي عقائدي خلاف مهني وعقائدي في
نفس الوقت هناك هناك
خلاف صحفي وميول والميول احيانا يتحول الى
عقيده ترى عند كثير من الناس
عجيب
طيب شخ المباره شفتها بما انك هلالي شفت
الهلال شباب
1411 الرياض المباراه الاخيره 90 دقيقه
يعني ايش
تبيش تبي توصل ل لا لا بس ما مصدق انك
تتابع كوره ليه ما ادري ك ماجبك كثير انا
عندي من اصدقائي يقول انا هلالي انا
نصراوي ما
يدري انا واحد كنت اتجادل انا واحد من
زملائنا يقول قول قبل فتره خلنا ناخذك
ميدان
ثاني كان يقول لي النصر جاب صفقات احسن من
الهلال والنصر
ا
ا مساعدين اكثر من الهلال مساعدينه اوكي
وهذه الصفقات ومسكت قلتها طيب من الصفقات
اللي جابهم الهلال سافتش وين يلعب قبل قال
ما ادري قلت له روبن وين يلعب قال ما ادري
قلت
طيب يعني مالكم وين يلعب قال ما ادري قلت
طيب وحق النصر قال عرف بروزوفيتش كان يلعب
في الانتر ساديو ماني كان يلعب في ليفربول
طبعا ما جا النصر من ليفربول جا من بايرن
ميون ورونالدو عارفه كلنا وين يلعب تجي
تجي تقيس على هذه المعلومات كل معلومات
نقليه ت يعني هو يقوللك النصر افضل ولا
الهلال افضل بدون ما يدخل في التفاصيل هذا
كثير في الرياض كثير بعد تويتر في كل
المجالات اعتقد انه في الرياضه طاغي على
الاقل خليني اقوللك ل انا ميداني يمكن
لاني قريب منه بالعكس
[ضحك]
يعني طيب كنت اقوللك الان
التعصب هل الاعلام هو اللي اجز التعصب ولا
التعصب هو اللي ابرز
الاعلاميين عمليه
مشتركه عمليه مشتركه في كثير من الصحفيين
وجودهم قائم على وجود التعصب هم يغذون
التعصب لانه يحمي وجودهم يعني هو لو كان
يقف بين كل الانديه لم يصبح له قيمه
ماد ف لما صار ضد
او يحمي او او يحاول انه يحارب وضد مع
قضايا ناديه بس كويس صار له موقع في
المدرج هذا بس في المدرجات الثانيه هو ما
عنده موقع هو ما يبحث اصلا عنده الموقع
لانه يعرف انه لن
يصل التعصب يعني هو ملح الكره وشيء موجود
مهم
ولاكلام يردد كثير مو رياضيين ولا يعني
مرض هو موجود موجود شئنا ما بيننا هو
موجود هو زين ترى على فكره في
المدرجات التعصب هو واحد من درجات الحب
انا بالنسبه لي العاليه جدا اللي لا ترى
العيوب ترى المحاسن فقط قد يكون ذلك
التعصب لمن تحب هذا
شيء من اعلى درجات الحب التعصب هو جزئين
انا هو قائم او واحد من دوافع الحب وواحد
من دوافعه كراهيه تجاه الاخرين هو كراهيه
و تجاه من تحب اكيد حب
قاطع انا اعتقد انه كثير من
الاعلاميين التعصب يحمي وجوده وهذا واضح
بشكل او باخر ارتماء في حضن مدرج
معين يحافظ على بقاءه لانه لا يملك
الادوات اللي هو يثك من نفسه في نفسه من
خلالها
ام ما يمكن باي حال من الاحوال انك تقنع
احد متعصب ترى في قوه وفي كل مكان
جماهير جماهير روما اظن الايطالي كان
عندهم لاعب اسرائيلي فرفعوا علمه في
المدرجات في نفس المدينه عندهم مين رفعوا
علم اسرائيل في نفس المدينه لاتسيو الفريق
الثاني في المدينه اوكي المباراه اللي
بعدها رفع علم فلسطين ما عنده لاعب
فلسطيني ما عندهم اصلا فهذه مواضيع الضد
والند اللي موجوده بين المدرجات انا
اشوفها عاديه في المدرجات ما في اي مشكله
هي متى ما انعكست على التقييييم الحقيقي
للعمل سواء العمل الاداري او العمل الصحفي
او العمل اتجاه المنتخبات او العمل هذه
هنا لازم نقول ستوب لازم يكون في احد لازم
يكون في احد حازم يوقف الموضوع بس في
المدرجات في
مشكله انا ما ما اعرف من يوقفهم هل
المفترض دور الحكومه هنا ضبط حاله التعصب
و المر انا اشوف انه
ا
ال الحاله الوضع العام تحول الى معسكرات
كويس وما في احد في الوسط في هذه
المعسكرات يدير هذه العمليه ايا كانت
رتبته سواء حكوميه او اجتماعيه او حتى
رياضيه ما في احد مقنع ما في احد قدوه في
هذا الموضوع يقوم بهذا الدور ا القواعد
الصارمه لما يمس الخطوط الحمراء او الخطوط
الحساسه يجب ان تكون موجوده ايش الخطوط
الحساسه يعني المنتخب الوطني لابد يعني
المفاهيم لاز بد تكون
واضحه المنتخب هو المنتخب ما حد يشابك يا
فريق منتخب هو من يمثلنا جميعا المنتخب
اللي هو انا والدي ما يحب الكوره ما ما
يتابع كوره ولكن اذا جفنا جالسين ونشوف
قال من يلعب نقول للسعوديه وكذا ق عسان
فايزين ما يحب الكوره بس انه في شيء دماء
تتحرك يعني ل هذا الوطن يعني المتخب لابد
ان تكون لازم لازم نقول ستوب للجميع عندما
تصل الى مرحله المنتخب لابد ولا بد ان تسن
قوانين في هذا الموضوع وانا ارجع واقول اي
ولا بد ان تكون المفاهيم واضحه انا وجهه
نظري وهذه زعلت ناس مني ومازل انا موؤمن
به هذا الشيء لا يوجد فريق يمثل الوطن الا
المنتخب ليه
الفرق تمثل انفسها حتى لو كانت تمثل الوطن
حتى لو كانت في بطوله خارجيه حتى لو كانت
في كاس العالم حتى لو كانت في كاس العالم
هذه هو يفرق هو الفريق هذا يمثل نفسه عندي
تعاطف اوكي ولكن ارى انه في ذك اللحظه يجب
بعد من سء اوكي يجب انلا يكون هناك احفظ
لسانك على الاقل يعني لا تشجعه بس احفظ
لسانك اوكي لكن تجي تقول المنتخب لا
يوازيه شي مهما كانت المشاركه ايش يعني
مثلا مثلا اذا ادى اداء سيء ما اقول ان اد
ادا لا لا اتكلم تتكلم عن جمهور الاعلام
اعلام الاعلام حتى المنتخب قالنا سيء اذا
ادى في مشكله فوين الخط الاحمر لا لا انا
اتكلم عن الخط الاحمر اللي مشاكل الانديه
اللي يتم نقلها وتصديرها لمنتخب مشاكل
اللي تصير في المنتخب
ويتم تفسيرها بان يعني دوافعها من الانديه
هذه اشياء الصحافه اللي اللي ممكن تلصق
بلعيبه المنتخب اشياء غير موجوده فيها
ا محاولات التفرقه بين لعيبه المنتخب بشكل
او باخر كويس حتى في حتى في المعلقين حتى
في اشياء كثيره لا المنتخب يمثلنا كلنا يا
اخي انا مره شفت مباراه يعني ما قيت شفت
في حياتي صراحه يا اخي احد في العالم
العربي يشجعون منتخبات بلدهم زي المصريين
والمغاربه انا شفت مباراه مره المنتخب
المصري في مصر رج الدنيا
واقفه مصر واقفه عن بكره
ابيها يعني بشكل ما يمكن وصفه في ذك
اللحظه الشارع واقف كل شيء في الدنيا واقف
المنتخب يلهب وتعال لم يجيب هدف ولا يجي
عليه هدف وترى على فكره يطلعون ويزعلون عن
المتخب بس في الاخير كلهم خلف المنتخب وتر
عندهم مشاكل اهلي وزمالك وعندهم مشاكل
كثيره وهذا موجود في منتخبات كثيره يمكن
احنا ما نقول
الاوروبيين اقل في النظر الى منتخباتهم
بهالشكل لان الاوروبيين ا اغلب لعبتهم
يلعبون في انديه غير محليه دائما لها ما
يظهر مع انه اجيبلك مثال
مثلا سلف لاعب مانشستر سيتي البرتغالي
اوكي سووا معه مقابله المقابله تختار فلان
او فلان يعني يقوللك شبوه بنفيكا ولا
بورتو يختار فكان من ضمن الاسئله قالله
ايزيبيو اللي هو اسطوره البرتغال ولا
رونالدو اسطوره في كاس العالم بس مش
الطوره يعني مقارنه برونالدو
فقال
رونالدو لا شك بان اسطوره البرتغال على مر
الاجيال واعظم من لعب كره القدم في العالم
كويس بس انا ام زيبي عشان من نادي
حقي يعني وناعم نسويله وهم مسوي له مجسم
على بوابه النادي فهذه موجوده يعني هذه
التفريق البسيطه موجوده في كل مكان بس انا
اقول لمنتخب يجب انه لا يمس المنتخب يعني
ا يعني لازم يكون له وضع الخاص في التعامل
معه حت حتى في مواضيع العقوبات مواضيع
القواعد
التعامل مع صحفيه كل شيء صراحه بس ليش
استبعدته يعني انا خليني اقوللك شيج بالي
استبعدت ايش يعني خليته على الجنب انه لا
يمكن احد انه خصوصا من الاعلاميين او
الصحفيين انه يتكلم عليه لا انا النقد ما
امنعه لا لا لا لا ما يمكن ارفضه فانا
اتوقع لا قلتلك سكان بوضوح خليني بقوللك
الشي اللي يمنع انها تكون ما ينطبق على
المنتخب ينطبق على كل الانديه لا اذا اذا
انت اتهمته بما ليس فيه تعاقب بالقانون
يعني بغض النظر يعني انه نروح نسن قوانين
جديده انت اتهمته هل عندك دليل عندك دليل
انت رجعنا لسؤال البدايه تر سحبت الافكار
من ابد يعني بس دخل لا سحبت الافكار كثير
بس ايش رايك في هذه الفكره ان ما في احد
بعينه وانما هو القانون الجميع لا انا قلت
لك قبل شوي ترى ما كانت هذه الفكره
الاساسيه بس نرجع الشريط نرجع نشوف نرجع ش
شي التعصب كان يعني اي لا اح نتكلم عن
المنتخب الجز اللي اخذتنا على المنتخب
اتوقع ان كنت تبيه تخليه على جنب لا لا ما
كنت ابغى لا انا اقول
المنتخب يعني يجب ان يكون له تعامل خاص ما
امنع النقد ترى ما امنع اقوللك اليوم تطلع
تقوللي المنتخب كان سيء بس انا قلت ادخال
الميول في الحكم على المنتخب هذه فكرتي بس
يعني نقول مثلا عبد الرحمن سي لانه نصراوي
اليوم ما العب زين في المنتخب لانه نصراوي
اوكي هذا غلط طيب من اللي يحميه ذا
النصراوي ولا ذا الهلالي ولا اللي من نادي
الفتح ها فكرتي ممتاز وبعدين عرج ايش رايك
في من يحكم هل مثلا اذكر انه كان في مجلس
الشورى
طالب رفع توصيه شي زي كذا والله اني ناسي
انهم انه ودهم انهم يسنون قانون لضبط
التعصب وعدم تشجيع تعصب في الاعلام وكذا
هل انت مع وجود هذه القوانين اللي تمنع
التعصب و تحاول تقنين ما يمكن السيطره ما
يمكن السيطره بس احنا نتكلم الحين عن
الاعلام ولا نتكلم عن جم
علام جمهور الجمهور موجود في كل مكان
جمهور جمهور اتكلم الاعلام الاعلام انا
اقول يعني عندنا اكثر من حل وهذه مسيره
طويله ابراز يعني تقديم القدوات
الصحيحه
محاوله
تعديل من حااد عن الطريق الصحيح يعني في
الاعلام تقديم نموذج للنشا يعني حتى النشا
يعني لما يشوفون عبد الرحمن والله قاعد
يطبل كل ليله لفريق النصر تى يسبونك انت
الصح تيجي تقوللهم المهنيه كذا واح ا حد
عنك انت
مهنك حقيقه هذه موجوده فتقديم القدوات مهم
بس انت لما
تجي كثير منه دور تقديم شوف التقديم مو
معناته انك تاخذه بيده في مواقف هي مواقف
تقديميه تتم في المجتمع بشكل او باخر هي
مواقف تقديميه انت لما
تجي عبد الرحمن كل ليله يطبل للنصر بيل
فاخر من النوع العظيم كويس اللي هو يحول
السواد الى بياض يعني في زعمه تجي انت
تقول يا اخي هذا انسان كويس
مقابلات وزير الرياضه بتروح عنده كويس
مقابلات مدرب المنتخب بتروح عنده
مقابلات بنسافر لكاس العالم بناخذ اول
واحد
بنسافر الاولمبياد بناخذ اول واحد شش معنى
هذا الكلام تبارك ما
يفعل صح ولا لاح
هذا نوع من
التقديم بس يعني عبم لا كير بس انت
النصراوي عنده مشكله مظلوم دائما حتى
بالاعلام وحتى
ضيف من
طلقاتك طلقاتي وطلقات طيبه ان شاء
[ضحك]
الله
طيب في وليد الفراج يقول
في لقاء له برض يقول خمس سنين القادمه
مفصليه في الاعلام
الرياضي يقول ممكن كل الاعلام الرياضي
التقليدي يختفي واللي حيبقى فقط الاشخاص
هم اللي ممكن يتحولو لمنصات حقيقيه
للمعلومات تتفق مافهم يعني مثلا اقدر اجيب
خاد القحطاني هو شخص بذاته على الشبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي ويقوم مقام مؤسسات
صحفيه بالوصول والتاثير ويقدم ماده
تحليليه الوحده في قناته الوحده الوحده
سواء في السناب ولا في تويتر تقدر برضه شو
اسمه الاردني على يوتيوب محلل رائع المهم
وعنده ملايين المتابعات
ا وعلى ذلك فقس يعني اللي موجودين على
شبكه التواصل الاجتماعي وتاثير على
التواصل الاجتماعي قد يكون احيانا اعلى من
في المرمى اللي هو على العربيه صحيح ما
عندي مكيا يعني نقدر نمشي في الفرضيه هذه
لا لا بس
اح اتوقع انقص تران عن لا لا انا بسالك
سؤال الحين على
موضوع المشاهدات المليونيه او كذا او
المتابعات المليونيه انا عندي متابعات
مليونيه بس ابقول الكلام طب هل هي مقياس
حقيقي لا مو كل المقياس لكن معيار مهم
معيار هل هو
الاول قد يكون احيانا انا بالنسبه لي لا
شخصيا اوكي بس بس متاكد انه في كل قيادات
الاعلام ما عندهم متابعات
مليونيه معلش ما فهمت كل اللي يقدون
المؤسسات الاعلاميه في السعوديه السعوديه
خلينا نقول ما عندهم متابعات مليونيه مث
ا تكلم مثلا اساسا مثلا
زي بو خالد ولد ابراهيم ما عنده حساب في
تويتر اصلا اه يعني يختلف يختلف د اوكي
واحد من قيادات الام بي سي علي جابر ما
عنده متابعات مليون ما في مشكله يختلفون
بس يعني ل ما هو عبد الرحمن راشد هل احد
يشك في قامته قيمه وقدرا وتاريخا وارثا
صحفيا حاضرا ماضيا لا ما عند متابعات
مليونيه ما في شك اي طيب هل انا بس بس لو
انت بتقدم برنامج وما يتابع انا متاكد ان
عبد الرحمن راشد في العربيه بيحذف برنامجك
لو ما يجيب متابعات مليونيه لو كان لا لا
الحين هذا موضوع انا اتكلم عن المتابعات
المليونيه هل هي مؤشر بسح في البرنامج اذا
كانت في مؤشر مهم لا لا انا اتكلم عن
السوشيال ميديا الحين انت خلطت موضوعين
احنا تكلمنا انت قلت واحد اردني عنده
متابعه عنده على حساب ترى اتوقع انك تحبه
يعني ما اتوقع اي والله اني ناس يسمع بس
والله ما اعرف منه انا اعرف خدق قحطاني
يعني نعم كفو يقدم ماده جيده
ا يعني حسب متابعتي البسيطه يعني مش
متابعه 100% ولكن يعني ممكن يكون يعني
واحد من اهم الناس لو تم يعني تاطير بعض
الاشياء
بجانب بالقواعد المهنيه اللازمه بس يعني
مثلا انا شفت كثير من الناس على
شفت اي احنا الحين الحين السؤال اللي نرجع
نقول حبيبنا
ا افتقاد القواعد المهنيه هي ابسط صفات
الاعلام الناشط مش مطالب بها مش مطالب بها
لكن برضه انت كونك على التلفزيون قد
يكون الاكشن هو اهم شيء تسويه عند البعض
اي اي عند البعض ايه انا لا انا ما احبه
فلا يلزم يعني لا لا انا ما احبه بس من
انه عند البعض ايه
اي في فرق بين بين الاثاره الموضوعيه
الماده اصلا تقدر انت تسويها وفي فرق بين
الاثاره الفارغه وفي كل مكان وفي اثاره
فارغه على التلفزيون صح فيقص انه لا يلزم
يعني وجودك التلفزيون لا يلزم انك تلتزم
بقواعد صحفيه مهنيه او اعلاميه مهنيه لا
هنا فارقه حبيبنا انت تتكلم شوف لحظه
خليني اقوللك شي بس عشان توصلك الفكره
عشان توصلك
بس احنا نتكلم انه القواعد الصحفيه اساسا
المهنيه مو شرط انها تكون في التلفزيون بس
هو مو شرط ان كل من في التلفزيون يتصب بس
هو المكان المناسب لها لانه هذه مؤسسات في
فرق بين الفردي والمؤسسات حتى على مستوى
انت تذكر زمان طلعت موضه اليوتيوبر وهذول
الع الناش وين راحوا
الان يعني في وفي في من اختفى وم استمر
على البص بس اغلم من استمر ما راحوا مؤس
اللي ما راحوا مؤسسات اللي راحوا مؤسسات
الغالبيه الع اللي تحولوا الى مؤسسات
الجانب الفردي منهم اغلبهم اختفى انا عندي
وجهه نظر انه حتى الاعلام الناشط هذا متى
ما تحول لمؤسسات يكون اعلام حقيقي ا بس
انه المشكله وشو يا عبد الرحمن هذا هذا
شيء ترى والله مهم جدا كثير ينظرون
للاعلام بانه عمليه سهله سطحيه اي احد
ممكن يقوم بها من الخارج كذا لما ينظر له
نظره من الخارج بس لما تدخل في عمق
الاعلام من الداخل هذه عمليه معقده الى
بعد الحدود ترى انت ممكن تقابل مع مسؤول
كبير ومع مسؤول صغير ومع رجل الشارع هو
ينظر الاعلام نفس النظره هذه بس تعال قل
لها ترى انا سوينا هذه كذا لكذا فما يدري
ان هذه العمليه تمت بهذا الشكل ومرت بهذه
المراحل حتى تصل لله وهذا الشيء هذا شيء
من للاسف
الشديد
ا تكد تكون نظره عامه في الفتره الاخيره
تجاه الاعلام للاسف الشديد يجيك واحد
يقوللك ايه انت انا بالتليفون سويت
الهوايل احنا ما نلغي وجود مثل هؤلاء
الناس لكن لابد نعرف ان الاعلام ايضا مهنه
لها قواعدها ومهنه لها اجراءاتها ومهنه
لها حدودها ومهنه لها قيمها يصلح انت تقول
والله واحد جاء امس صحى من النوم وفتح له
حساب على سناب انه صحفي ما يمكن احنا ما
نلغي وجودك انت موجود انت موجود لكن لست
صحفي بس ممكن تكون اعلامي
ولا ما يعني شوف ترى انا منين اللي شفتها
عندك في الحلقه انت سالتها نفس السؤال حتى
ما ا جا قال لك ما ادري هو م علامين ولا
مو والله ناسي يمكن عبد الرحمن راشد ما
ادري هو اظن عبد الرحمن يمكن يمكن اتوقع
هذا كلام انا والله والله انا نفس الشيء
تصدق يعني انا ما اعرف انت
يعني اذا تجي على المهنيه ما فيها اي سبل
او او طرق تسلك للمهن اذا انت احيانا تقول
بعض جوانب المهنيه ههم لا يحتاجونها
صحيح الحقيقه صحيح طيب ش المعايير اي
المعايير اللي اذا بغى ارجع
برضه الاشخاص اصبحوا منصات يعني ممكن نقول
انه المشاهدات معيار صح تاثير معيار ش
باقي عشان تصبح منصه يعني
صحفيه صحفيه او
يعني يعني هي الخطوط والله يعني تحس انه
الموضوع متشرب يعني بشكل او باخر احنا
يمكن حقين الاعلام التقليدي ندافع
نافح عن هذه المهنه وفي واحد يجيك يبسطها
يقوله يا اخي ترك ازعجت نبذ المهنيه حقتك
شش المهنيه ترى ما در عنها الا اثنين
ثلاثه وماتوا خلاص ما بقي منهم احد ف تيجي
تنظر للمشهد تقول والله عنده جانب يا اخي
من الصحه صدق ترى ما حد عند المهنيه اللي
انت قاعد بس هي يا اخي عبد الرحمن نوع من
الرضا الذاتي في المهنه يعني انت لما تجي
تعمل مهنتك بقواعدها واساليبها وتنافح
عنها هذا نوع من الرضا الذاتي الداخلي لما
تجي واحد قاعد يعلم الناس بشكل خاطئ
في في عن المهنه انت يا اخي تستش غضبا
تحاول انك تناف عن حدودها لانك ترى انه
انتهكت وهذا اللي قاعد يتم الان بين كثير
من التداخلات اللي بين المنصات الفرديه
اللي يرون انفسهم اعلاميين كثير مثلا من
الاعلاميين الاعلام تقديم وقعوا في
المحظور ليش لانه الاعلامي اساسا اساسا ما
اقول دائما ولكن غالبا الاعلامي هو
الحقيقي المهني يستطيع الرقص على الخطوط
الحمراء دون ان
يقع كثير منهم الحين هم يعني
ا موقوفين مثلا لسبب او لاخر لاخطاء فادحه
وبعضها تر فكر اخطاء سطحيه هذه ايضا واحده
من الفروق اللي انا انا ممكن اقيم المشهد
على اساسها طيب معلش انت مع مين انت انت
مع مين الاعلام القديم ولا الجديد انا
بستخدم نفس عبارتك انا هنا المذيع انا
اللي اسال ما قلتها وين قلتها قلتها وين
مع ابو ناصر لقائك يوم والله ناسي والله
اني
ناسي طيب لكن انا ودي اسال يعني هل تتعارض
المهنيه مع استخدام ا
الانترنت الجديده ابدا ترا ابدا ابدا ابدا
نتكلم المهنيه المهنيه مين بالمنصه وراهم
قادرين نفسكم طيب الصحافه مؤسسات شوف
الصحافه هي الصحافه في كل مكان تختلف
الاداه مثلا الصحافه الورقيه كانت الاداء
ايش القلم الصحافه الالكترونيه كانت ادا
الكيبورد صح الصحافه التلفزيونيه الكاميرا
والمايك الاذاعيه هي الصحافه الاداه تختلف
بس احنا نتكلم
الحين يقوللك مثلا الموضوعيه ما هي
اشتراطات الموضوعيه ان تقف مثلا
على نقطه من البعد متساويه بين طرفي
القضيه ان تنقل الخبر كما هو بدون تدخل من
رغباتك الشخصيه ومنافع
الخاصه ان تكون قريبا من المشهد لتنقله
مثلا هي كثير طبعا الاشتراطات البعض يقول
انه انه حتى فيها اشتراط فرعيه اللي هي
لابد ان لا تنقل عن ناقل اوكي في اشتراطات
كثيره هل هذه كتابه الخبر
الصحفي يعني احنا وصلنا مرحله خلينا نتكلم
على موضوع الصحافه الالكترونيه وصلنا في
مرحله من المراحل في البلد اي واحد عنده
لابتوب ويفتح موقع يقول انا رئيس
تحرير مرين الفتره ولا لا بعدين جت وزاره
الاعلام سوت
تنظيم سووا تنظيم في ذك المرحله انه لا ان
هذه من يفتح لهم اشتراطات التاليه وصار في
تنظيم نتكلم عن الخبر حتى يا عبد الرحمن
لما تجي تقرا في بعض المواقع الخبر ما
تعرف راسه من
قفاه يعني حتى الخبر هذا لمن ينسج كخبر
الخبر يفرق عن التقرير الخبر لابد ان يبدا
بفعل لابد ان يبدا بليد ما في تفاصيل
ثم المتن تكون فيه التفاصيل ثم التصريح ثم
الخاتم في باك جراوند لما سبق هذه الاشياء
ما ما تكتب بشكل او
باخر العناوين او المشات في الصحافه ما
يجب ان يكون فيها حرفين جر الصوره في
الصحافه ما تبدا من
اليمين المانش ما يكون فيها اسماء موصوله
هذه قواعد مهنيه هل هي موجوده في الصحافه
الالكترونيه
انتدر انت انت اعلامي
بعد هذه طيب هذه هل كسرت هذه القواعد طيب
انا اسالك سؤال من الجهه الثانيه المعسكر
الثانيه اني هل هي
مهمه اساسا ولا لا يعني هل هذه القواعد
مهمه ولا كسرها ترى ترى ما كسرنا المله
بيقول لك واحد اذا هو يعرفها وكسرها ما
عندي مشكله ما عندك مشكله اذا هو كسرها
لغرض معين لا لا ما ضد تقديس القواعد لا
مو بتقديس القواعد يعني كل مهنه لها لها
اصولها اي اهم شي انك تعرف اصولها وم ثم
عاد تسوي اللي تبيه يعني اذا رايت استفدنا
من معرفتك لانك انت تدري وتدرك هذا يعني
اذا بنجلس خلاص هكذا وجدنا ابائنا عليه لا
مو هكذا وجدنا التطور ياتي في المفرده
التطور ياتي في التناول سؤالي مو بسؤالك
بس سؤالي كان اي بس انا بقوللك انت تعرف
الادوات المهنيه الصحفيه وانتم اهلها انا
صحفي انا لا املك مؤس صحفيه انتر مؤسسه
صحفيه
[ضحك]
المفروض ما المعنى من انكم تستخدمون
الادوات الانترنت الجديد او ادوات
الانترنت
الجديده مين قال ما نستخدمها بالتالي
تنزلون بي دي اف يعني والله يعني مفترض
تزون بيدي اف تغريد لا لا لا من اللي قالك
هذا جزء هذا جزء انت جيت على واحد من 100
طيب نفسهم انا ما عندي مشكله تدري احنا
لحظه لحظه خل بجيك على الرياضيه ما براح
العربيه اوكي الرياضيه عندها قسم خاص
بالسوشيال ميديا صح ايه عندها قسم
الالكتروني الرياضيه في المناسبات تغطي
سناب اوكي
وتغطي انستقرام اوكي
وتغطي اكس او تويتر اكس الناس لسه ما
تعودوا عليها ف وتغطي تويتر وتغطي الموقع
وتغطي ورقيا طبعا اخر المراحل قلتها لك
اكيد انه المرحله الورقيه ليست الاولى ولا
الثانيه ولا الثالثه الان حتى الموقع
الالكتروني نكون جادين لكن احنا نغطيها
مهنيا نغطيها بالطريقه المهنيه يعني انت
الحين يا عبد
الرحمن لو
جاك هذه واحده من القواعد مثلا لو جاك
رئيس نادي الهلال كويس واعطاك تصريح ضد
رئيس لجنه الانضباط مثلا اوكي يعني ارجو
انه ما يفهم اني اخترت رئيس الهلال بس جت
في بالي عشانك ف لما يجيك
التصريح بهذا الشكل من المهنيه انك تذهب
رئيس الجبا تقول عندنا تصريح كذا كذا هل
لديكم رد هو امام ثلاث خيارات هم يقوللك
لا تعليق فهذا رد هذا رد لا تعليق هو رد
هو تعليق او يسكر التلفون في وجهك كويس
يعني قصدي
انه ما يستجيب كويس وهذا مو رد هذا تنتظر
شوي كويس او انه يعطيك
رد اوكي انك تنشر بدون الرد كويس هذا يعني
احيانا عيب مهني يعني في جزء من الانحياز
كويس هذه مثل هذه الاشياء م موجوده عند
الزملاء الجدد هو ينقل بس هو ينقل بس احنا
احنا مثلا الان لما نستخدم الاعلام الجديد
في الرياضيه
كمؤسسات وانا من خلال اسئلتك عرفت انك غير
متابع للرياضيه بشكل كويس تغطياتها ف احنا
لما نروح نسال احنا حتى في السوشيال ميديا
في الجوانب المهنيه المنصات الجديده احنا
يعني التزم بالخط المهني يعني لما يجينا
عبد الرحمن انا ما اشك في مهنتكم والله لا
لا انا انت انا انا اشك في متابعتك ما
عندي مشكله شك زي ما تريد زين بس ش بعدك
تعرف ليش لانك انت تقول انتم تنزلون هذه
جزء بسن يعني انا بالنسبه
لي هذا اللافت لا انت اراك ارائك الخاصه
لا تعممها لا لا بس انت لما تشوف هذا انت
قا اول شي عبد الرحمن انت مش مش مش ترى
احبكم زي يعني واجد ما
عليك هذه يعني بغض النظره هذه ذاتيه وهذه
موضوعيه بما ان نحكي عن
الموضوعيه المحبه لا المحبه المحبه لا شك
فيها ابد القلوب عند بعض ولك احنا نتكلم
في اطار يعني خلينا نقول علمي مهني اي
بشكل او باخر انا اشوف انك غير متابع جيد
لما تاخذ هذه كا استشهاد لان حتى البي دي
اف حتى البي دي اف اللي انت شايف الخبر
الرئيسي اللي هو خبر يتم
تقسيمه يعني ينزل كتقييم بس احنا كيف انا
اصلا
اساسا الصحافه الورقيه جذورها عميقه في
انفس الناس القدماء هم لما تجي انت تبي
تحولهم تقول يا اخي انا مسوي ترى موقع
الكتروني واغطي في المنصات دي واغطي في كل
شي يقوللك المنش ليش ما كتبت اليوم عن
النصر ترى انا مغطي هناك لين قلنا بس
يقولك لا للا ط ترى المشت جزء بسيط من من
عمل طول اليوم قاعد
يصير طيب يعني انا ايش في يدي اسوي عشان
اقنع الناس هذا
الموضوع افضل عبم عطنا وجهه
نظر عندي وجهه نظر انا مجرد يعني بس لما
انا اشوف بيدي اف بس انه يلفت انتباهي
يعني قرات ما بعد ليشي ك قريت ما بعده
يعني انا اشوف اشوف التغريدات كلها قريت
ما بعده قريت ما قبله يعني شفت ايش منازل
ايكم تنزلون كثير و كثير لا والله كثير
انا انا انا بالعكس مشغول العمل اكثر من
قاص اشوفها بس هذك عاديه لانها الد فان ما
نظرت لها بس هذه اللي لفتتني في معلش قلي
الجزئيه اللي عندك احتجاج عليها وجود بيدي
اف في تغريده
بس ما عندي احتجاج
طيب نقطه او مصدر دهشتك يعني انك تنزل
صوره الصفحه الرئيسيه زي ما هي يعني هل
باقي احد يقرا يمكن انت عندك معلومات انا
ما ادركها لا انت تنزلها اول شيء انت ما
عندك حد ائتماني لموضوع التغريدات اوكي
فانت تنزل الصفحه الاولى ثم تفصلها خبريا
ليش ليش
اي انت لو اشتغلت في الصحافه الورقيه
الورقيه حتحب شيء اسمه الاخراج
الصحفي افهمكم شوف هذا هذا وحده من امتع
فنون
الصحافه اوكي من امتع امتع ومن اعظم رؤساء
التحرير اللي هو دائما يرسم بنفسه مثلا زي
محمد التونسي تخيل رئيس تحرير يمسك الم
الكيت حق الصفحه وال مرسم ويرسم صفحه وانا
ما اشتغلت مع عبد الرحمن مثلا ولا عثمان
صحافه ورقيه ما ادري والله هم يرسمون ولا
لا ولا قد سولفت معه بس هم طبعا الثلاثي
اللي ولا خالد المالك يعني ولا مثلا تركي
السيري الله يرحمه يعني رموز صحافتنا
الورقيه كانوا ومنهم من تحول بعدين الى
الى صحافه العصر الجديده و وانسجم معها
ومنهم من توقف
ف هذا واحد من الفنون اذا احنا ايش المانع
يا حبيبنا ان نقدم هذا الفن في تغريده
صفحه بي دي اف ثم نذهب نفصل او فصلنا قبله
ونزلنا استمتع باخراج الص الصفحه وبما
شتها ثم الخبر وزعنا انت اللي ما تحب
الصفحه الاولى على تغريدات اخرى اقراها
مباشره واستمتع فيها بذوقك هذا ذوق وهذا
ذوق لكن لم نقدمه ترى على فكره كعنوان
رئيسي للجريده لم نقدمه كعمل الابرز
للجريده لكن ما عمل مادر نتجاهله اح يوميا
عندنا على سبيل المثال عندنا شيء اسمه
صوره اليوم ينزل على تويتر بتعرف ليش
سويناها ز سويناها لانه عندنا كثير من
الصور مثلا نحب نستثمرها غير انستغرام
وغير ونبي نشجع
الصوره واحد من اجمل الصوره الصحفيه فنون
الصحافه وفي مسابقات عالميه لها وفيه
وفييه وف
طبعا خليي
اقول من الاشياء اللي قل تاثيرها في
الفتره الاخيره لكن الصوره شيء يعني في
الصحافه شيء عظيم المصورين لا يقلون ان لم
يكن يتفوقون في الصحافه على الصحفي نفسه
يا اخي صوره واحده عن الف خبر طيب احنا في
هال الفتره هل هذا الفن موجود حاولنا
نحييه ترى على فكره الشركه السعوديه الاس
ار ام جي كان عندها يوم من الايام مجله بس
خاصه بالصور ايش كان اسمه
[موسيقى]
اهكس اظن او شيء زي كده يعني والله ناسي
اسمها بس بس كانت الصوره اكيد ما في ايوه
فحنا نتكلم هذا هذا هذا الحديث جرنا على
فنون كثيره من الصحافه انا اعلم وانت تعلم
كثير من المشاهدين الان يعلمون انه الناس
ما عاد تقرا المقاله المطوله وشيء لكن
هناك من استمتع بها
السؤال ما تزل تقرا
روايات الروايه كم 500 صفحه اقل روايه 200
صفحه و 220 مثلا بس نستمتع بس لها وقتها
الخاص الخبر المطول ما اصبح عنده قارئ بس
التقرير الصحفي اللذيذ انا ما اقوللك تحول
الجريده ثلاث صفحات كلها تقارير صحفيه و
وكل تقرير 500 كلمه او 400 كلمه لا لكن لا
بده يكون هذا موجود خله موجود اوكي جزء من
السلطات وجزء من الاطباق اللي موجوده على
السفره اللي يبغى ياكل واللي يبغى يحطه في
في الثلاجه وياكله بكره ما في مشكله بس
هذه الفنون موجوده يجب انلا تموت الخبر
الصحفي السريع اللي صار
العواجل العواجل العواجل شلون وجدت
العواجل وجدت يا اخي لانه الصحافه الورقيه
اصبح هناك من يسبقها اوكي فما صار عندها
فرصه انها تصيغ الخبر بالشكل المتكامل
اللي
هو لديد
الخبر القصه
التفاصيل المتن او السند ثم الخاتمه ما في
وقت الناس ق معرف الخبر وانت تكتب ذا
الخبر اصبح هناك عواجل في الصحافه وفي
التلفزيون صحيح فايضا ه الصحافه قاعده
تطور نفسها من خلال
ادوات جديده تحاكي العصر ليش احنا لما
ننزل الصفحه الاولى وننزل الصفحه الاخيره
ولا نغطيها بهذا الشكل يقول لك شو اسمه
اخطيت اب اقوللك قصه ترى مهمه في
واحد عنده مناسبه مهمه حافيه ما جملنا
فيها حطيناها على الموقع
الالكتروني فقلت له هذه التغطيه قال له
وين
المشت هذا اللي انت رافضه ما يزالون
الناس تتناقش مع الناس انه يا جماعه هي مش
بالمتر في التغطيات مش بالمتر ترى يقوللك
لاماش كثير من الصحف حول العالم حتى في
السعوديه كثير من الصحف توقفت اصبحت بيدي
اف على الموقع هي تشتغل مواقع الكترونيه
فيها تغطيات واخبار ومقالات واراء وارا بس
البيدي اف موجود استمراريه البي دي اف نوع
خليني اقوللك من الارث نوع من
جماليه الجماليه الاخراجيه فكره رومانسيه
فكره رومانسيه يعني الناس اللي يحولون
يكسرون القواعد المهنيه لانه ما يجدون لهم
طريق فيها
مثلا
الن
طيب ايش في ما ادري ليش تعتقد
انم لا تقول اشياء انا ما قلتها وتحولها
الى حقائق في الحوار حقائق يعني نقطعها
وزبطها ايو وانت في منتج ممتاز تفضل ان
الادوات الجديده بمختلف انت ليش تصورني
على اني رافضها لانك انت را رافض
كقول لا لا انا رافض كسر انا رافض كسر ال
قواعده المهنيه على كل المنصات اشتغل باي
منصه تبيها بس لا تكسل القواعد بالقران
طيب اي بس هذه مهنه ابد بس يعني اللي حط
الفكره ذي تقدر تطور عليها على فكره ترى
الفكره الوحيده الفكره الوحيده بضرب لك
مثال في الشرق الاوسط واحده صحيفه عريقه
جذورها في التاريخ يعني كمدرسه ستايل
الشرق الاوسط لا تكتب ستايل لا تكتب مثلا
الاقتصاديه هم في نفس الشركه صح
ليش المتلقي الاهداف تختلف الشرق الاوسط
عندها لغتها الاقتصاديه عندها لغتها
الرياضيه عندها
لغتها ستايل بوك الرياضيه
مختلف عن ستايل بوك الشرق الاوسط تماما
يعني حتى في كتابه الشهور ابسط شيء هذه
الاشياء اللي انا قاعد اقول لك ترى ما
ينتبه للقاري العادي هذه من اشياء يعني لا
لتخصص كل المهنه عبد الرحمن لا تروح بعيد
الان على التيك توك مثلا ولا على سناب كم
عدد الناصحين طبيا كثير اوكي مهنيين لا
شكرا اي انا ممارس للرياضه محب وممارس
الرياضه حتى الان حلو كويس واهتم بال يعني
درجه الهوس بالتغذيه واشاهد كثير من
الاشياء مااني بقوللك اني انا بس انا
بالخبره من سنين واسال الاطباء مختصين
بالمجال كثير من الاشياء تق غلط وكثير من
الاشياء تقال متناقضه اذا احنا لازم نحافظ
ترى في كل المهن على قواعدها انا على
فكره انت لا تفهم التمسك بالقواعد ضد
التطور لا تفهم ولا ارجو انه ما يفهم احد
من مستمعينا ابدا مو ضد التطور انت ممكن
تتطور ولكن الحفاظ على الهويه هويه مشو
الهويه حتى الهويه مش ما عندي مشكله فيها
اتكلم على قواعد المهنه شيء ضروري جدا طيب
يوم اطلقت شمس هل جوك صحفيين اخرين من صحف
الثانيه وقالوا ان اللي انت تسويه غير
مهني وانك جالس هذه ل ما كانوا حابين
موضوع التابلويد
بس على فكره التابلويد ليش ضد الصحافه
مهنيا هي التابلويد
عرفت في الصحافه الغربيه بان التابلو
صحافه فضائح اوكي ليست صحافه رصينه ولا
صحافه
رسميه الحجم عرف بهذا الشكل اخذت عننا
صوره يعني زي الالوان عبد الرحمن الالوان
في صوره عنها اللون الاحمر في صوره عننا
كذا اللون الاخضر الى اخره يعني في هي صور
نمطيه في اذهان الناس ايضا صحافه
التابلويد كان في صوره نمطيه عنها كان هذا
اختلاف بينا وبين كثير من رؤساء التحرير
الكبار في ذك الفتره بس مو معناته ان ما
كنا مهنيين فان ما قلت انك ما كنت مهني بس
بالنسبه لاخرين كنت منت مهني لا لا لا طيب
اخرين في نقطه شوف في نقطه فيها سوء تفاهم
بيني وبينك في في الموضوع للان لا ابغى
اقول لك بحدد لك شيء احنا مش ضد الحفاظ
على القواعد المهنيه ليس ضد التطور هذه
لازم نتفق عليها قواعد التطور لحظه لحظه
خليني اقول لك شيء المنصات تتطور كويس
القواعد ليست قران مقدس والدليل الدليل يا
عبد الرحمن في قواعد اساسيه وفي قواعد
فرعيه القواعد الاساسيه هي الصحافه
القواعد الاساسيه كتابه الخبر هذه قواعد
اساسيه القواعد الاساسيه الى الى الى اخره
بس يا اخي انا قلت لك قبل شوي عن
الاختلافات بين مدارس الصحفيه الشرق
الاوسط والاقتصاديه والحياه سابقا كانت
مدرسه صحفيه وهم كانوا كلهم صحفيين
حقيقيين بس هذه مدارس موجود في كل المهن
اختلاف ما بنختلف اب تحمست طيب ايش رايك
في اختلافك مع ابو محمد مع داود اي ليش هو
نظر للفكره بهذا به تبع ما تابع انا متاكد
انه ما
تابع يعني يمكن تابع عدد و ما تابع اللي
قبله تابع تغطيه شاف صفحه اولى بس ما شاف
الموقع وهذه معاناه نعانيها مع كثير من
الناس انه يجي يقوللك زي ما قلت قبل ش
يقوللك المشت يا اخي المشت ترى حاله تتم
الساعه 12 بالليل بس باقي ما قبلها في
اشياء كثيره غطيناه الناس ما تتابع هذا
الشيء مش انا ملزم ترى على فكره ان نطق
بيوت الناس نقول ترى كتبنا هذا الشيء اكيد
ان من ملزمين وفي نفس الوقت
الناس لهم الحق يعبرون عن ارائهم ولهم
الحق يعبرون عن ما يرون صحيح سواء داؤود
او غيره لكن اذا وضح لهم كويس فالحق وحق
حق يتبع سواء معي ولا ولا ضدي ايضا انا ما
عندي مشكله ترى عبد
الرحمن يعني ما اعتقد اني انا انسان يعني
ارفض الراي الاخر انا في في الصحافه لي
سنين بالعكس تقبل كل الرا لكن قدم لي رايك
بصيغه تعبر او تنبي عن الاحترام لا تتبجح
ولا تنتفخ على الاخرين كانك انت تعلم كل
شيء وهم لا يعلمون ناقشني بكل احترام
واناقشك بكل احترام سواء انا اختلفت
وبعدين زي ما قلت انت في البدايه هي ترى
قواعد مش قران مقدس يعني اذا كسرناها
بندخل النار لا ترى ممكن انا واياك نختلف
بس كلنا محترمين بلا شك اوكي اذا لا تتبجح
وانت تقدم رايك للناس ولا تنتفخ على
الاخرين قدم بكل احترام ونحترمك حتى ممكن
ما نرد نقبله وما
نرد انت عندك انك تقول انت ما عندك مشكله
مع اختلاف واضح عندك مشكله اختلاف مثلا
هذا هذ
القه انا قاعد اناقشك انا قاعد اناقش يعني
الحين اذا اذا لحظه دمان دمان لحظه لحظه
انت تبيني اقبل بس رايك عشان اثبت لك اني
مش مختلف معك
نعم بس حسك جاي ما ادري يمكن النصر ماثر
عليك ما اعرف والله بس بس جاي ب النصر
كويز الفتره شلون ياثر عليك المفروض تاثير
ايجابي طيب النصر شفت انك ما تتابع لا لا
ما تتابع ما ما تابعتي ما
تابعت نصر من عرفته مظلومين مظلومين ها
شوف المظلوميه في الوسط الرياضي شعار دارج
عند كل من ما يكون كويس اليوم الهلال ما
مظلوم دائما يعني ما يظلم يظلم تار طب ترا
اعتراف خطير ضدك موصح لا ابدا الهلاليين
موضوعين اي بس هذا اقوللك هذا اعتراف خطير
ضدك موص
انا ما امثل كل الهلالين تمثلهم ما امثل
اقوللك انت تدور الزله دور الزله وت
خابرني كفو يا لا لا والله وانت كفو 60
كفو طيب شو اسمه ليش ما ف صحف
او مشاريع رياضيه جديده طلعت في المشهد
يعني خلال الفتره الماضيه بينما تقدر
تشوف مشاريع في مجالات ثانيه في الثقافه
ولا في الفن ولا
في حتى ممكن احيانا في السياسه الا
الرياضه رغم انه شعبيتها عاليه ممكن يكون
فيها فلوس اكثر الا انك ما تقدر تشوف
مشاريع مستقله جديده في في المجال الرياضي
اكلم عن مستوى المنصات مستوى المنصات يعني
مثلا زي ثمانيه ما هي مشروع رياضي هو
مشروع يعني تقدر تسميه ثقافي ام بس وفي
مشاريع كثيره في مجالات مختلفه لكني ما
اتذكر مشروع رياضي فليش هذا الكلم على
مشروع رياضي ان منصات جديده طلعت اس اس سي
مثلا مشروع جديد اوكي لا بس هذا مشروع مو
مستق يعني مسي تابع لوزاره الرياضه او
تشرف على وزاره الرياضه اظن كان كان يعني
بس انها من رحم بس هذا مشروع جديد اوكي
هذا مشروع جديد س نقصد مستقل
ا يعني ما اعرف والله ش ش
الاسباب يمكن رؤوس الاموال ما عندها ثقه
في المشاريع الرياضيه يمكن يمكن هذا واحد
من الاسباب يمكن ايضا الرياضه دائما تدخل
ضمن التفاصيل وليست عنوان مستقل مثلا
ثمانيه يعني زي ما قلت انت مشروع ثقافي
الى اخره ولكن يستضيف رياضيين ص اوكي ففي
داخله الرياضه وليست عنوانه العريض يمكن
يكون هذا السبب يمكن رؤوس الاموال
الرياضيين ترى طفار مو زي المثقفين عبدم
يبغى نستثمر ما تك العيش الرياضه اج
الاستثمار في الرياضه مربح على كذا ممكن
فكر انت كمستثمر فكر ليش لا بالعكس في
جانب في الرياضه انا اشوف ما احد طرقه ال
شغل الوثائقي في الرياضه ما هو موجود يعني
موجود
بشكل بسيط
جدا حتى على فكره ترى من انجح الافلام
الدراميه الامريكيه افلام رياضيه كثير
ناجحه الى بعد
الحدود يعني في مادري شفت لاست دانس
مثلا مايكل جوردن رائع جدا وانتشر انتشار
يعني الناري في الهشيمه لا انا ما اتكلم
وثائقيه لشخصيات لا انا اتكلم على افلام
الرياضيه الدراميه مثل ناسي والله
عناوين قاعد اتذكر وانت
تتكلم بس في موجود يعني بس الاكيد ان ف
الاكيد ان فيها وهي وهي يعني ناجحه في
العالم العربي ما في افلام وثائق جيده
يعني حتى تخيل عبد الرحمن ان رموز للرياضه
مثل ماجد عبد الله اوكي مثل مثل سامي
الجابر مثل
محمد
نور انا كنت بطلع من الكوره بس انت رجعتنا
يعني كنت بطلع مثلا اقول سعد شداد بقول
خالد العيد الدهامي رمزي هذول عندهم
ميداليات اولمبيه اوكي اهم الميداليه
الاولمبيه من اي شيء لعبه جماعيه اخرى
تخيل ما عندهم افلام وثائقيه سوين واحد مع
مين هذ صان هذه صوعان سونا في المتاب و
ممتاز هذ صوعان سلك المتابع لا تتابع
ثمانيه بشكل جيد لا لا اتابع اتابع والله
الحقيقه ان مش متابع بشكل ممتاز ولكني
متابع الله يحفظك يا طيب ليش متمسك
بالعربيه انا بقوللك ليش عندك فرصه وظيفيه
عندي فرصه
وظيفيه لا والله بس انا يعني دائما استغرب
ليش يعني العربيه هي
قناه يعني عندها وصول عالي وكل شي ما
نختلف لكنها نخبوي تابع نخبه يتابعها
اساسه يتابع الناس لكنك الرياضه ما هي ما
هي جوهم يعني قد يكون بس الرياضيين في
اماكن ثانيه يح قد تكون حتى اذا انت يعني
تحت منظومه ام بي سي فيي زي عبد الرحمن
اذا انا في قناه نبويه واصبح يتابعوني
الرياضيا هذا شيء ممتاز اي بس انا يعني ما
كنت ما جت ليش تمسكت بالعربيه يمكن والله
انا يمكن يمكن الوصف انا احب الرياضه ما
في شك ما انكر هذا الشيء احب الرياضه مسه
واحب الرياضه متابعه ولكن اذا جينا لجهه
الاعلام ارجع واقوللك وصف لزميلنا صالح
خليف الله يذكر بال الخير كان دائما يقول
انا صحفي يعمل في الرياضه وليس ولست صحفي
الرياض انا الى حد ما شبيه بهذا القول
خليني اقولك انا احب الصحافه بشكل احب
الصحافه ما اعرف اشتغل غيرها حاولت اكون
بزنس مان وفشلت بفشل دريع عشان ك كنت
بعدين اقوللك تحت الهوا
ف يعني ما يمكن اكون ما اعرف غير ه المهنه
ما اعرف يعني اشتغلتها وانا طالب في
الجامعه وتدرجت فيها بين الصحافه الورقيه
الالكترونيه المنصات الى الاعلام
التلفزيوني انا كان خطين مسارين متوازيين
ما بين الصحافه الورقيه والتلفزي في نفس
الوقت وحتى اذاعه اشتغلت ما في منصه يعني
اعلاميه ما اشتغلت فيها
فاحبها واستمتع فيها ما يمنع انه يكون تمر
بحالات احباط زيك زي انسان يعمل في كل
مكان يمرر احيانا حالات نفسك انك ما مشيت
في هذا الخط ولكن هي خطا ولا بد تكملها
العربيه انا بالنسبه لي واحده من اهم قلاع
المهنيه الحقيقه اسست على ذلك واستمرت
اكيد انها مرت بلحظات وهن وبلحظات ضعف
زيها زي كل المجموعات اللي في
العالم وزيها زي كل اي جسم اعلامي موجود
يمر بلحظه صحه ولحظه مرض ولحظه ولكن انا
مازلت اقول انها من اهم القلاع المهنيه
وليست
الاعلاميه يعني عندها هويه عندها شخصيه
عندها قواعد واضحه انا فخور اني اشتغلت في
في العربيه وما زلت انا متمسك فيهم يمكن
هم متمسكين فيني ايضا اظن اعتقد بس ماكن
مثلا ما ادري متى سان يغادرها لا الصحفي
يتخلى عن
مهنيه مثلا متى
يكون متى يعني كيف يتعامل
مع خبار اللي لها علاقه بالوطن مثلا شوف
خل خليني بقوللك فلسفه نرجع لموضوع الحياد
والموضوعيه طيب في جدل تاريخي حول
الموضوعيه عند اهل الاعلام واهل البحث
البحوث الاجرائيه او البحوث بحوث بشت
انواعها حتى البحوث
الاكاديميه في دائما خلاف بينهم على موضوع
الموضوعيه ما بين الحقيقه وما
بين النموذج التخيلي الجميل الناس في كثير
يقوللك الموضوعيه يجب ان تكون موجوده وفي
ناس يقوللك هذا موضوع هذه قضيه تخيليه لا
يمكن ان تكون باي حال من الاحوال الموجوده
وصلوا الى منطقه وسطى في مرحله تاريخيه
المنطقه الوسطى قالوا بان العلوم
الانسانيه احنا لا نشترط فيها المهنيه ليش
قالوا لان الانسان هو مجموعه من المشاعر
والت حكومات المعرفيه والخبريه والحياتيه
لا يمكن ان تفصل عنها كلام صحيح طيب ز
الباقين قال اذا لم اذا هو مو صحفي قال
طيب اوكي لنتفق في منطقه وسطى الجوانب
الانسانيه ما يطالب فيها الم يعني
مثلا اي جاء فريق اخر قال طيب خلونا نكبر
الصوره مين يؤسس الاعلام قالوا شركات
وحكومات قالوا هل يؤسسون لشرف لهدف نبيل
دائما او لاهدافهم الخاصه فانقسمت الاراء
ما في حد قال هدف نبي بس انقسمت ما بين
اهداف خاصه واهداف سياسيه واهداف اج اهداف
اقتصاديه قال طب اللي دفع فلوس في كل هذه
الاشياء من اجل ان يقاتل على
الموضوعيه اذا الفكره من اساسها
نسفت فكره الموضوعيه صح اذا وصلنا
لهالمرحله اتفقنا عليها نسفت تماما ما
اصبحت موجوده لكن في فريق ما يزال يقوللك
الفريق اللي يتمسك ب
ا يتمسك باشياء ا انا في راي ان اندثرت
كويس يعني في في بس كان لا الموضوعيه في
جوانب الموضوعيه الموضوعيه في جوانب
البحثي موجوده الموضوعيه في جوانب الصحافه
الى حد ما موجوده الا دخل
مصطلح عدم الانحياز ودخل مصطلح الحياديه
ودخلت مصطلحات اللي اللي شوي
ا خلينا نقول تمازجت المفاهيم فيها فاصبحت
الصوره ميب واضحه ما بين الموضوعيه وما
بين الحياديه وهل الموضوعيه منهج صحفي او
منهج بحثي مقبول في البحث وغير مقبول في
الصحافه وهل الحياديه موقف او
منهج طبعا جو يتكلم عن في في الابحاث قيل
بانه
ا لا يجب ان تكون موضوعيا في بعض
القضايا لا يجب تخيل لا يجب تكون موضوعيا
في بعض القضايا وصلت الى مرحله انه في سنه
1996 نقابه الصحافه الامريكيه اسقطت مصطلح
الموضوعيه
من من يعني خلينا نقول ادبيات الصحفيه
اسقطت تماما متى اعتقد اشوف طبعا بس عشان
اسند انا لان قاعدين نتكلم في شيء يمكن
الناس تنقله كمعلومات كامله طبعا انا ما
قراته في اي شيء يتصف ب او يتصل ب نقابه
اسحاب قر في مقال اوكي بس عشان يكون واضح
1996 وصلنا الى هالمرحله ايش بقى من
الموضوعيه ش بقى منها الموضوعيه البحثيه
موجوده الموضوعيه البحثيه هي ضد الذاتيه
موضوعيه في النقاش هي ضد الذاتيه انا لما
اجي اقول عبد الرحمن انا وياك قاعدين
نناقش فكره اوكي بس انا قاعد اقول يا اخي
ش انت انت اصلا اصلا بالله هذا شكل برنامج
وانت طالع مسوي كذا رحت انا وتركت
الموضوعيه هذه موجوده اوكي الاختلاف دائما
اقوللك زي ما قلنا في بدايه حديثنا
الاختلاف وتداخل المفاهيم في الاعلام ترى
كبير جدا جدا جدا تخيل انه في
في في الجوانب البحثيه بعض الناس اشترط في
في امور البحث او بعض المتخصصين
انك يجب ان تتخلى عن
عن كثير من المسلمات وتدخل مع نفس الفريق
اللي انت تبحث عنه كما انت واحد منهم عشان
تتخلى عن
الذاتيه اقول لك طبعا مثال بعد الحلقه على
هذا
الموضوع ننهي الحلقه عشان
تقوللي لا هذا شيء يعني في في يعني مر
عليه في موضوع البحث الاجتماعي واحد كان
يبحث عن فئه من الناس فاضطر ان يشاركهم
نفس التفاصيل عشان عشان يكون
موضوعي
اه تحديات والله الله يعطيك العافيه والله
ل مليت مني مليت
خلاص تعبت افا انا والله شف في حياتي سويت
لقائين حبيبي وانا استمتعت معك الله يسك
شكرا لكم شكرا لمشاري حمود في اعداد
الحلقه ووهاب موسى خلف الكاميرات عبد
العزيز المزي في تسجيل الصوت محمد الحسن
في الهندسه الصوتيه ومحمد نور شمت في
التحرير وعبد المجيد العطاس في التلوين
وفي اداره محتوى التواصل اجتماعي نوره
السبيعي ومنتج البرنامج ايمن الحمادي
واداره التحرير اسيل ب عبد الله هذا فنجان
احد منتجات الشركه الثمانيه للنشر
والتوزيع نشر كل الانتاج بحب من مدينه
الرياض في الاسبوع المقبل
[موسيقى]
الق انا عندي سؤال بدما ان كذا الحين عشان
باخذ منكم خبره انتم حق الفن الوحيد اللي
ما سويته انا البودكاست فب اسوي بودكاست
لازم اجي كده بدون شماغ في البودكاست و
ولا ما يطلع بودكاست لازم ما يطلع بودكاست
ايش السبب ليش لا كلهم كذا لا لا م علك
انا اقوللك يعني ين اللي يجون لابس كاب
يجي مفسر ريديه كذا ومشمر شماغ وشعر مو
مرتب لازم نسوي كذا عشان ط هل لازم البس
كرفت ولا ما اقدر اطلع على العربيه ستايل
جري قناه مش ت بطلع ماخي عقالي لا استيل
قناه طيب فالقص هو انت ستايل انت اختارنا
سؤال سؤال لا على موضوع القناه على موضوع
القناه انت تروح للعشاء زي ما تروح
لاستراحه عش رسمي لا طيب ممتاز اقوللك
احنا نقول نعتقد والله
اعلم الهدف هنا مش ماغ اذا لبستها فيها
رسميه فيها رسميه وان الناس ان انت تقدر
تكون تقدم ماده افضل وتقرب للناس اذا انه
حسينا انه احنا متكين في استراحه جاسين
سولف او في مقهى هذا احنا سو انا ماي
علاقه الناس برا ثمانيه تسوي في ثمانيه
نقول كلهم صاروا كذا يعني ترى مكن انتم
اصبحت قاده
للمرحله ممكن وممكن انه هذا ديدا في
العالم يعني انه انت تقدم ما تشبه الناس
اقرب للناس يعني احنا شعرين نقول ان احنا
صحافه تشبه الناس يعني ممكن البس شماغ
وانا اقدم بودكاست ما يمنع ابد تقدر تسوي
اللي تبي لان هذ الاشياء اللي لفتت
انتباهي في البودكاست كلهم كلهم صاروا كذا
ف انا قاعد اقول انا افهمك ترى قبل شويه
تقول ان نوع
من المسج انه تسهيل الحوار تب حتى الضيف
بسيطه ان انا ودي ان الضيف ياخذ راحته هذا
مبسوط اصلا بس فهذا الهدف والله قلت لك من
البدايه يعني مبسوط مع اني احسك جاي وانت
دفاعي بشكل لا لا لا والله انا ترى رجل
حماسي فا اسلوبي كذا يعني في في الحوار
وانت
يعني يمكن انك بس حضرت ح سنه 2008 بس هو
ثمانيه اي شيء علاقه ثمانيه انا حطت له
غير ثمانيه ما هو رقم مميز رقم مميز متاكد
لا رقم مميز جدا ام حتى في النحو صار في
رقم ثمانيه مميز ليه ا انتعرف قاعده النحو
حق الثمانيه ولا ما تع لا والله وو
الثمانيه ا
طبعا التعداد في اللغه العربيه مثلا
مسلمات قانتات صالحات تائبات ثيبات وابكار
في ثمانيه سميت واو الثمانيه اوكي تيجي في
الثامنه وكلبهم باسط ذراعيه وثامنهم كلبهم
بس اللي قبل ثلاثه رابعهم كلبهم خمسه
سادسهم كلبهم فسميت ثمانيه
طبعا اغرب شيء في في الموضوع موضوع
ا يدخلون
جنه يعني يعني شي هذا طبعا مش تسجيل الان
عشان ما ابغى اخبص بالقران ها
[ضحك]
ط داخل لا الموضوع النوا الثمانيه مهمه
يعني على رقم ثمانيه ثمانيه كان يلبسها
فهد الهريفي واحد من اعظم لعيبه الوسط
التيماوي تماوي واحد من اعظم من اعظم
الاصدقاء والرجال غير الملعب والله ب 60
نعم والله نعم
كلهم بس فث رقم رائع بس الشاهد
ششو ايش كنت اقوللك ش 8 ا تبغى تسوي
بودكاست اي ودي انك تسوي شي مختلف والله
يعني هل لو اعطيتك كل شيء انت تبغاه ام ش
شكل الصحيفه اللي انت ب تعرف انا انا
اعطيك موارد لا محدوده ايه اللي انت بيه
ابدا من الصفر انا انا اقول انه الرياضه
الان هي المكان الوحيد اللي تفتح فيه
قنوات هي والسياسه بقيه الاشياء فاشله في
الوقت الحالي افتح منصات لا تفتح
قنوات اوكي منصات بس شوف اس اس سي ايش را
تجربتهم اس اس سي رياضيه ايش رايك تجربته
ا ه تسجيل ولا م تسجيل
تسجيل والله شوفي اذا طلعت الغرفه لا لا
بقول لك شيء عاد اقوللك شيء لا والله اقول
لك رايك بالصراحه مشكلتي انا ازعم ان
مشكلتي واحده من مشاكل صراحتي ازعم ازعم
اس السي
ا بدايه كانت مش واضحه مش واضحه هم اصلا
يعني ش يبغون مش واضحه بدوا يعودون الى
الى تقييم
انفسهم يعني ومحاوله ايجاد الطريق اللي هو
بيوصلهم للاهداف من جديد ا هل هي مقنعه
جدا انا بالنسبه لي حتى الان غير مقنعه
لكنها في الطريق عندها عندها صراحه كفاءات
جيده مش واو عندهم كفاءات جيده زملائي ما
يزعلون من دك ياخذونه منه اخوهم السبير
يعني في ولكنهم يعني يحتاجون الى لو نقل
الدوري بي ان سبورت بيكون احسن بي ان انا
مين معجب تجربه بي ان لا
ايه ماني معجب بالقدرات اللي فيها بصراحه
كويس لكن الامكانيات الضخمه لا جدال لانها
توافرت على اعظم امكانيات توافرت لقناه
تلفزيونيه مش بس رياضيه عندهم يعني كم شوف
كم المراسلين الهائلين اللي موجودين شوف
كم الاستديوهات الهائله موجود شوف كم
الضيوف ترى ضيوف الرياضه اكثر ضيوف تدفع
لهم اكثر من اي مكان اخر تر السياسه ما
تدفع لهم فلوس السياسه ما يعني انت بتستي
وزير بيقول لك كم تدفع اكيد ما حيقول لك
تستضيف وزير سابق بيقوللك كم تدفع واعط
الرياضه كلهم يقولون طول طبعا يقول لك اوك
خلاص اوكي حكلمك مدير
اعمالي وتتعاقد معه بالشيء الفلاني اه اي
احنا كنا نفاوض قبل فتره واحد
انجليزي مع تغيرات الدوري فنجم من نجوم
الكره الانجليزيه فقال لي
ابغى ابغى لا لا مش بكم قال ابغى 400
دولار شهري اي فقلت قلت لها كم قلت له
يعني العش ب 40 مثلا احسبها انت قلت
لها يعني يا كابتن احنا قناه نيوز مش قناه
رياضيه قال لي انا رايح قناه نيوز في
تركيا يستضيفون على الدوري التركي دافع لي
40 تدفعون اكثر ولا لا ف الرياضه ترى
مصاريفها هائله الحقوق في الرياضه يا عبد
الرحمن كم تشتري
الحقوق يعني الهايلايتس كم تشتريها يعني
تجربه عندكم في قناه الشرق ما عندك اوعدد
ننتهي ايوه شوفي قناه الش كم اشترت
الهايلايتس برضه بشي هايلايت بس بس ملخصات
بس المشكله يا اخي ان والله يعني اني يزعل
يعني لما اتفرج الدوري السعودي ليش يعني
مجوده انا والله ما اتفرج استديوهات
تحليليه كث في بعض المباريات يقولونها 4
كي بس حتى يعني تبقى ما ادري في تخبيص
قصدك انت في حركه الكاميرا والخراج حركه
الكاميرا حتى الريفريش ريت حق العدسه يعني
اشياء ما ادري والله يعني فترق الكوره
تنطط يعني واضح انها اذا نشتت بسرعه يعني
ام اشياء تقهر يعني بسان ان شاء الله ان
شاء الله ان مطورون ان شاء الله مطورون ان
شاء بتجاربهم يعني هم اللي موجودين جيده
ان شاء الله يكونون افضل في المستقبل انا
والله مننوع اللي يعني صراحه ما اشوف
الاستديوهات ولا التغطيات اللي قبل ولا
بعد حكم الشغل بس ال 90 دقيقه اشوفها يعني
مرضيه الى حد ما مرضيه مش رائعه يعني
بالنسبه لي مرضيه اشوف 90 دقيقه بس
الله يوفقهم اط افكار طيب جديده انت قدم
لهم مشروع قدم لهم شي مافهم الرياضه ولاع
الرياضه تبع الرياض ق واخوهم الكبير
بعد حم ليش تق عبد الرحمن تتابع الهلال بس
وتقوللي
ماتابع الحين ترجع تقول ماتابع يعني
ايشك لاللا والله
لا المنتخب
الكوريا وكريك ولا ايش كسك ايوه لا ما
تابعتها ما تبعت جد جد ش علاقتك في
الرياضه علاقه طيبه يعني يعني يعني تصل
لحد خمسه من عشره لا تصل اذا قطعت يدي
تلقاها دم ازرق
الله لا جيت من الاخر
انت لا لا بس اتابع مبرا فقط مباريات مهمه
يعني شفت امس
الاهلين المباريات اللي كذا مع انك
المفروض اهلاوي انت لا ما احس لا ما لا لا
انتم يعني وولد انسان الفتره هلالي بد
انتم اهل الجنوب كلكم
اهلاويه لا والله ادري ابوي شجع الهلال
ترى ابو شجع الهلال اي بس لسبب غريب ترى
ايش عايش في الرياض هو لا ابد عايش في
الجنوب يعني هو شجع من الجنوب بس سبب غريب
يب غريب انه ولد في نفس السنه اللي تاسس
فيها نادي الهلال الله
فاعجبه فشج لا بس هذا ارتباط غ7 ارتباط
غريب ليش انه يعني شجع الهلال عشان نفس
السنه بس الحمدلله فكل العائله هلال فكره
احنا بيتنا
متنوع مشكله في نص في اتحاديين تخيل شوف
اتحا ما عندي مشكله بس ما عندنا
اهلاويين هلين هلاليين اتحاديين اتحاديين
اخوي
نواف ولد في
فتره يعني يعني فهم يعني
وعى على قولتهم وعى في
فتره الاتحاد
الذهبي محمد
نور وكار وكريري والعالم المجانين دول
اللي اخذوا اسيا مرتين
وكذا شب
على واتحاد كان فريق منصر بلوي لا كان
فريق يعني عظيم على طص بلوي اي اي رؤساء
الانديه شوف الافضل من اللي
عاصرتهم
طبعا شوف انا صرت ناس فتره وانا صغير يوم
كنت في الجامعه واشتغل ما كان عندي الوعي
الكافي لحكم صراحه يعني ما كنت اظلم ناس
يعني يعني مثلا
انا حقت على سنوات بسيطه مثلا من عبد
الرحمن سعود كويس بس كنت لا شي يعني هامشي
في الصحافه اصلا توني اتعلم وتوني ما عندي
الوعي الكامل يعني ايش رايك في اللي قال
عليك قال عني اشياء كثيره سويت لقاء قبل
الله يرحمه ما يموت لقا صحفي قال عن اشياء
كثيره ترى دائما بطال قال مره عني بطال
رحمه الله عليه الله يسامح ويغفر له من
احسن الناس في الرياضه اي مشفنا من الاكل
خير يعني بس نقول الله يسامحه من باب انه
من
الاموات والله يا عبد الرحمن في نقطه مهمه
لازم تنتبه لها وانت تنظر رؤساء الانديه
مثلا اقوللك عبد الله بن
مساعد مو لان صديقي هم كثير اصدقاي ترى في
كل الجوانب يعني عبد الله بنساعد نظم
الهلال من الداخل بشكل ليس له مثيل في
الانديه السعوديه هيكله وشغل والى اخره بس
ما حقق بطولات الرسه الاولى عبد الله بن
مساعد ما حقق الا بطوله واحده تخيل كاس
دوري ما جاب وشي ما جاب فلذلك التصنيف هنا
في يقولك عبد الله ما نجح مقر براسا
الهلال الثانيين لكن هو من الداخل اشتغل
شغ هذا الشغل من الداخل ما حد يدري عنه
ترى ما حد ينتبه له ما حد اصلا يتكلم عنه
يمكن كثير من رؤساء الانديه نفس الشيء
سووا هيكله داخليه سووا تنظيم مالي سووا
حوكمه قبل كل هذه الاشياء ما تكون
اشتراطات
سووا
يعني اشياء مستقبليه بعيده المدى بس هذه
ما نظر لها ما تنظر في التقييم
الجماهيري على مستوى الفكر
واللعب والخبث والذكاء انا اعتقد ان
نوف بن سعد كان
خطير يعني كان من و
مستوى حتى الوفاء عند الكلمه واشياء كثيره
من احسن الناس تعاملت معهم انا يعني
صراحه ذكي جدا جدا جدا في تعامله مع
الاعلام وذكي جدا جدا في اداره ناديه ولا
يفتقد للمكر ولا يفتقد
ل الخبث ولا يفتقد قد يعني
ل اللعب على المراحل يعني ممتاز جدا جدا
فيها
هذه واحد من احسن الناس اللي صراحه تعاملت
معهم او او من احفض الرؤساء اللي انا
تعاملت معهم عندك ايضا عبد الرحم سعد ما
كان سهل كويس بس مر
بمنعطفات صعبه
كثير النصر ما تقدر تقول ان احد يصبر اصلا
النصراويين يعني قوم
يتنازعون يعني لا اي شيء فهم النصراويين
تلقاهم مثلا يقيمون للرئيس ابدا تقيمات
غير عادله ايضا النصراويين في ناس يقولون
دائما الهلال الرئيس يجي يكمل ما بعده ما
قبله النصر يجي ينسف ما قبله اساسا
النصراوي اللي جاه ما لقى قبله
شيء هذه حقيقه يعني ما لقى شي ما لقى شي
عملي
عملي منهجي عشان يك كمله كله اجتهادات
فرديه ويجي يقول واحده من سيمات الهلال
الاستمراريه لانه يكمل مقب النصر لا ما لك
شيء هو كذا لا جا طلع لقى لقى النادي كذا
لقى رئيس ناد اي لقى لا لقى الامور كذا ل
ف مضطر انه يبدا من جديد البلطان كيف
علاقتك معه البلطان انا وياه اصدقاء العل
الداء ام يعني نحترم بعضنا ونصل الى مرحله
الصداقه يعني الى حد ما خرج الكوره وداخل
الكوره يعني نلعب انا وياه مع بعض نلعب و
تو احيانا يعني واحيانا
يعني نتحايل على بعض بس هو رجل ذكي في
اللوائح تحديدا ذكي
جدا ماكر ماكر من الدرجه
الاولى يعني
و البلطان جني عفريت عفريت بمعنى الكلمه
والصراحه يا اخ اخي يعني عبد الرحمن واحد
ناديه يقع بين انياب الهلال
والنصر ويظهر للضوء اوكي يقول لك الناس ان
ارتمى في احضان الهلال ووجد الدف وما ادري
وش تعاند الهلال هو فتره صحيح الفتره
الاخيره صحيحه هذه يعني الى حد ما صحيح بس
هو برضه مو سهل يعني مو سهل ابدا والصراحه
يوم تشوف الشباب قبل ما يرجع بلطان رجعه
الاخيره وما بعده تشعر ب يعني تقول يا
البلطان شكرا جزيلا نادي كان واقف واقف
واقف بس بوجودك بس قبلك النادي كان ضايع
ضياع مو طبيعي والحين ض س عنده رجل ورجل
تحدي ويجيبها من يمين يجيبها من يسار
المهم توقف الدنيا كيف ما يهم ام وشرس جدا
طيب الحين بال نافل ب مسلي
الحيلي اي هم حال بعض كلهم
شوف رياضيا
يعني
رياضيا واداريا يعني اداره رياضيه مسلي
اقربهم ليش لان اشتغل في الرابطه وبن
الرياضه والى والى
اخره انمار انا والله ما اعرفه عن قرب
يعني علاقتنا بسيطه مش مش هذك العلاقه
يعني
القويه بسيئه ولا جيده بس ما عرفه عن قرب
بصراحه عشان احكم عليه فهد عرفه يعني الى
حد ما
عنده ميزه ممتازه اختيار الفريق ممتاز
عنده الايمان بالتخصص ممتاز عنده قاعد
يسويها في ادارته وه اياء الاداره
الممتازه
وفوق هذا عنده فريق عنده فريق ممتاز يعني
يعني فهد
ا دعوه مباركه جابته في هذه الفتره ما جا
فتره ثانيه كيف العمل اللي قدمه نواف بن
سعد طول تاريخه اوكي وجزء بسيط ل عشان ما
نظلمه بعد سامي في ثلاث اشهور سوى تعاقدات
هائله للهلال لا شك صراحه فثلاث اشهور
اللي هو قعدها
رئيس فهد جاء لقى كل شي تمام عنده يعني
الفريق يعني سوى لمسات بسيطه كان كان
يتوافر على افضل جيل في
تاريخ تبي تيجي تقول الجيل ما في اثنان
صحيح ما في اثنان بس ما في احد حقك كاسيه
مرتين زي كذا ورا بعض تقول الجيل ما فيه
سامي الجابري بس ما في حد حقق الدوري ثلاث
مرات مره الهلال حق الدوري ثلاث مرات
متتاليه في
تاريخه بس دوري المحترفين عنده سبع القاب
اظن سبع القاب اذا ما ابناس انت هلالي
علمنا كم لا لا انت الصحفي انا مو صحفي
المعلومه لا المسلم لا يجب ان يكون حافظا
القران
صح يجوز انك تكون مسلم تدخل الجنه وانت
حافظ القران انا ادخل الجنه دائما يخلص
هذا اللقاء وانا سفيني ليش لهالدرجه انا
سي الله يلا انا بمشي انا بمشي والله لا
والله